breaking news is coming out of arizona
and georgia pertaining to what's
happening with those audits and we can't
talk about it here on youtube and that's
just reality so i absolutely would love
to but the moment i actually report the
news of what's like there i watched a
video some testimony and uh it's
testimony but of course
youtube would delete the show instantly
so here's what i can say we will talk
about that over at timcast.com in the
members podcast and uh we'll probably
have some articles up about it uh
tomorrow the site isn't even fully
launched yet our soft target is monday
so hopefully by then we can actually
start producing things on the site that
we can't produce on facebook twitter
youtube or otherwise that's kind of why
we made the website they said hey go
build your own i said okay i will but
there's other news i guess
you know pertaining to what's happening
with these states and how people feel
about it you've got joe biden's constant
talk about civil war ad nauseam recently
he he effectively said that the gop is
the biggest threat
to democracy since the civil war now he
was specifically referring to these
voting
uh rights legislative bills that the
republicans are trying to pass
and of course the democrats call him
voter suppression bills the reason why
he i say he effectively said republicans
are the biggest threat is because
you can't separate the gop from the
bills they're trying to pass
if the fight is now between democrats
and republicans over how the elections
should be held and neither agrees and
one side says your plan for the election
is wrong
when joe biden says it's a threat to our
country or democracy or things like that
he's not talking about you or me or
anybody in this room he's talking about
his group of voters against the other
group of voters and that's where things
get really
bad i guess because they have a new poll
maybe it's bunk polls aren't always that
good i mean i'm not a big fan of how
these polls work but it shows that
essentially 35 just over 35 of this
country wants their region to break away
from the u.s effectively balkanizing the
country into five different regions now
the numbers vary in in the west
california oregon washington and alaska
it's 39 that want to break away in the
south it's 44
and i think the heartland they call it
it's 30
but when you add them all up
that's a large portion of people who
want this country to break apart and uh
what i guess i guess what do people call
it peaceful divorce has been has been
the conversation so you know upon seeing
data like this i'm not entirely
convinced the culture war will end with
one dominant faction it may very well
end with
five smaller regional unions
and
we'll see how that ends up playing out
if at all
otherwise i think there will be some
very serious
conflict if joe biden is saying things
that basically says the republican the
gop is a threat to us and he's willing
to use the fbi to go against
trump's base
you see where this is going you know
it's gonna be get me in power and i will
use that power to crush half the country
we can't have that that's getting crazy
so we're going to get into that and a
bunch of other stories joining us today
is the actual justice warrior because
social justice warrior is no good is
that is that how it works yeah do you
want it well my background's in criminal
justice and i think there's one true
justice and that's individual justice
all the other
qualifiers are not justice so actual
justice warrior so what do you do
so i make youtube videos on the
internet.com actual justice warriors the
channel and i do a lot of criminal
justice related stories i do a lot of
responses to the young turks everybody's
favorite progressives
and um and i i like economics so i'll do
some economics videos here and there we
also have news about the consumer price
index as well so we should definitely
talk about the food shortages the price
increase inflation rates what are they
saying now they're scared home buyers
are not going to be able to buy homes
because inflation is going up yeah okay
that's the reason i mean sure it's a
reason but we'll get into that yeah the
real reason is the black rock and stone
and stone blackstone are buying them up
so i got a couple of black rocks myself
i'm slowly falling in love with obsidian
you guys that's very cool i can't drag
it less yeah i can't tell if it's soft
or if that's my bones
i think it's your bones i feel like it's
form fitting to my fingers when i press
on it yeah it's not soft it's it's it's
just hard to feel it you know if you
crack it it's like the sharpest blade
literally it is really dangerous they
say um
uh what's the word what's the word but
it's atomic well if you slice it like in
really really thin it's the sharpest
substance known a man they used to use
it for eye surgery up until the advent
of lasers yep right very cool that was
like i watched a video of a guy trying
to make an obsidian sword not easy to do
he couldn't he couldn't do it's brittle
that's why so he tried to like put iron
into it and it doesn't work yeah it was
ceremonial mostly arrowheads and like
ceremonial oh yeah you know i actually
have a deep dive on that whole blackrock
thing and i i think you got it from the
wall street journal article right
there's actually a couple different
articles it's blackstone and blackrock
there's two different companies doing
two different things but that's actually
probably one of the most misreported
stories ever i did a 30 minute deep dive
into it and it turns out that what they
ended up buying and they may have not
even bought it they might have just
facilitated the transaction was a rental
community like something that was built
up specifically to be a rental community
i think you're you're you're mixing up
that there's two different companies you
you know there's there's one called
blackstone and one called blackrock
right and they're both engaging in this
one of the companies bought a rental
company and one of them is buying up
houses and then trying to put them under
rental management i
i don't i don't think that's the case
because i looked it up in the wall
street journal i'm not the wall street
journal i looked it up in single family
homes it's something like only one
percent of them are owned by investment
firms and they didn't buy a rental
company they bought like rental
properties that were already right which
one which company i believe this is the
one that was in the wall street journal
which was they're both in the wall
street journal well this is what
confused us and people in the super chat
were like you're wrong it's black rock
not stone and we pulled up both stories
and i'm like so
apparently there used to be one company
they split off a long time ago they
became two companies and they're
engaging in similar but different
practices right
i'll i'll just say this to the best of
my understanding and i could be wrong
because we'll definitely have to but it
was black stone was formed in 1985 then
black rock one of the founders i believe
uh cracked off in 1988 and started black
rock and i could be mistaken on which
company and all that like i didn't i
didn't have this like readily in front
of me but the single-family home
purchases it's a small portion of the
market and it's not a very profitable
investment to buy it and turn it into
rental property do you mean like a small
portion of of the market right now like
right now
because
do you mean like of all of the houses
that
are are owned one percent are owned by
investment yeah around one percent
that's massive actually it's it's not
that unusual it was more during the end
of the financial crisis and remember
they couldn't manage all these
properties so if you remember like 2013
2014 they were selling homes for like 30
000
or destroying them because it's like if
you buy up all these individual homes
then you're not like there's no way you
can assess and maintain them i don't
think we can accurately litigate this
right now um because i'm wondering if
is it one percent of all the purchases
of the past year or is it one percent of
the existing market it's the current
it's as of 2020 so like 2021 there could
be a giant surge it's just i don't like
if if you lived in a neighborhood right
and there's 20 houses in the
neighborhood the first 10 go to a
company like what are you going to do
when they come to offer on your house
like you're going to jack up the price
because you're going to think there must
be oil or there's some reason that
they're buying all this up this is why
when investment firms typically buy
single-family houses they're already
designed to be rentals
and i remember there's like a big
misquote in that article where they say
they paid um 50 above asking price like
some of the financial youtubers like the
real nerds about this they reached out
to the developer and he's like no no i
got 50 gross profit because i built
before the supply shortage before the
fed cut interest rates and and i sold
after all that so it wasn't actually
like you know 50 above asking price and
i did a mathematical breakdown of that
purchase and it takes something like
18 years for that to be profitable
assuming like no interest rates and blah
blah all this other stuff
i think the biggest problem here is that
there's two companies and it sounds like
you're mixing them up right but it's i
still i have my doubts of like big
finances buying all this because being a
landlord's pain in the ass well yeah but
you don't have to actually be a landlord
you just call a rental company and then
they do everything for you and it's
super easy so there's there's actually
the wall street journal talks about
blackstone and then every other outlet
is talking about blackrock because
they're both doing similar things
and they're very similar companies
and people rock and stone like but we'll
we'll get to that in a minute
let's actually do this
we've got a a sponsor it's biotrust
go to strongerbonesandlife.com
strongerbonesandalife.com and you can
get 51 off of this ageless
multi-collagen what does it do you say
it makes your skin stronger it makes
your bones stronger makes your joints
stronger it's great for your joint your
joints your hair your skin your nails
and if you're a 35 year old skater like
myself you definitely want to be taking
this stuff but i'll tell you
you guys you got to be taking care of
yourselves you've got to be eating right
being physically active it's very very
important and so if you are you know
past your prime well not really past
your prime but if you're not a teenager
anymore you want to get this stuff again
go to stronger bones and life.com and uh
51 off one of the coolest things about
it is that you actually get they give
you this like health and fitness guide
you can call them up it is
i want to make sure i'm getting this
absolutely correct but it's it's for
life like you you do one purchase you
get free shipping and um
what else can i say other than this that
it's a it doesn't it doesn't clump it's
really good ian puts it in his coffee
it's amazing you mix it into your coffee
and it makes like a little cream it
makes it a little yeah yeah you see it
like frothing at the top it's delicious
yeah the easiest way to explain it i
guess is uh well first of all go to
strongerbonesandlife.com link in the
description below and and check it out
and um it's it's this is important stuff
you know we're we're doing supplements i
guess i'm so glad you're involved with
biotrust i'm glad they sponsor the show
too because there's a there's a lot of
sponsors that we have but i always try
to make sure that we're
we're it's stuff we use you know so like
every every day at the show ian will be
like can i get some of that for my
coffee and i'll be like why don't you
just wait till we're like doing the show
and i'll just do it pass it over and do
it live yeah i don't know what what do
you like about it ian we normally don't
don't do the spot this way but um i like
that it's cream that it
produces a cream that's not dairy it's
not like cream but it like makes a nice
yeah it makes it kind of almost like
sticky creamy like smoothie kind of
smooth never clumps um
and i mean besides the the actual like
the the flavor and stuff just the fact
like collagen is so good for your joints
right your skin cartilage and stuff yeah
and your lips and if you're a woman it
makes your skin more luscious just
gorgeous lips i mean that's my my
favorite part about it we normally i
feel like we normally do a lot of the
sponsor spots really dry
and i was like i don't know man look no
i'll tell you i'll tell you the most
important thing i think this stuff's
great because i'm physically active but
as michael malus pointed out when we did
a promo spot when he was on the show
last time these companies that are
sponsoring the show are the ones who are
making
our communication possible they're
helping make this show exist they're
helping you know all the stuff all the
good work you think we're doing if you
like the show if you like the website
it's because we have sponsors like
biotrust so if you're gonna go get
collagen you wanna go to you wanna go to
strongerbones in life.com and if you're
not getting collagen you should and you
should go to strongerbonesandlife.com so
there's our unorthodox promo spot for
biotrust we love you guys and don't
forget go to timcast.com
this is this is what the alpha looks
like right now go to timcast.com become
a member you'll get access to exclusive
members only segments we're gonna have a
members podcast coming up talking all
about this election stuff but that'll be
over at mcas.com probably up around 11
p.m or so because
let me i'll just live with you guys we
literally can't say the words
i can't show you the news article
youtube would delete the video there's a
video of a guy he's talking giving
testimony if i tell you what he says or
even show what the guy testifies to
youtube deletes the video
so
how will i better serve you by just
getting banned i won't but i can tell
you go to timecast.com
become a member we got more shows coming
super excited about the shows we have uh
outside of just the tim cass stuff the
website's gonna be massive you're gonna
get tons of bang for your buck and i
really appreciate everybody who is a
member don't forget like this video
subscribe to this channel share the
video really just share every video you
watch from creators you support be it
actual justice warrior or stephen
crowder or people like stick sex and
hammer you can tell those are the those
are the the youtubers like i like and
probably watch them i'm always shouting
them out but uh sharing is the most
important thing so let's jump into this
first story before we do one thing that
didn't happen is lydia did not introduce
herself i did not she is slaying it over
there thank you i appreciate that you
know i'm here because the show is going
on and if i weren't pushing the buttons
there would be no camera switches so
that's me i love you thank you thanks
ian i appreciate that we can just do an
audio version then we got to worry about
the camera that's true yeah there you go
all right all right all right let's
let's let's talk about the story check
it out swanky site so we got this uh
from timcast.com shock poll two in three
southern republicans want to secede from
the united states
and this story is actually based off of
uh a a little quote tweet i had when i
tweeted at chen cougar
jank of the unturned says according to a
new yougov poll two-third of southern
republicans want to secede from america
where have i seen this movie before but
this time it's a confederacy of dunces
led by king dunce trump by the way when
you want to betray america that makes
you by definition un-american oh man
jake
you got those southern republicans they
want to secede from the union how dumb
are they you know anybody in any
political faction that wants to must be
really really dumb oh hey let me pull up
the poll that shows 47 percent of
democrats in the west which includes
california want to secede from the union
too hey where have i heard this story
before it's like a confederacy of dunces
led by who you jenk listen listen
okay two-thirds is a lot 47 percent a
little bit less than half but come on
we're talking about in the west the
largest faction of people that want to
secede from the union according to the
the the poll that he cited
our democrats last i checked jan kyuger
is a democrat and is within that faction
that has nearly 50 percent of their of
of their base wanting to secede from the
union so um what's the saying uh you
know living in glass houses and throwing
rocks people people in glass houses
shouldn't throw hard stuff yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh man you got to love
the young turks though but check this
out so here's here's the actual data
well it is true that the southern
republicans 66 percent are in favor of
seceding from the union effectively this
is this effectively is a balkanization
where you've got the pacific region the
mountain region the heartland region
northeast and the south
you can see that in the mountain region
43 percent of republicans want to secede
35 percent of independence now here's
the one that really made me laugh in the
heartland which is basically the midwest
43 of independence the plurality want to
secede from the union so there's
something about being in the midwest
where they're like we don't like
republicans or democrats
i get i feel that i think it might have
something to do with the fact that
chicago minneapolis very very democrat
so the people there are very unsatisfied
with democrats party politics is is crap
in my opinion people that get all tribal
and they're like i'm good because i'm
part of this group like come on man give
me a message say something that's
actually part of the analysis when
they're going through the data they said
it may be not that they actually want to
secede from the u.s to form new regional
unions and again this poll is literally
asking people would you want to
balkanize the united states
it may be that they're trying to virtue
signal that's what one of the
researchers said like these people are
asked and like i'm a proud democrat and
i support the you know or i'm from the
the west or whatever
let me tell you something
it's uh
there's there's two different versions
of how many people wanted to declare
independence in the american revolution
for some reason for a while people
thought it was one-third in favor
one-third opposed and one-third
abstained but that was based on a letter
from john adams where he was actually
talking about the french revolution at
least that's the modern historical
interpretation
so the best data i could find is that
it's between 40 and 45
of the colonists wanted to declare
independence wow 15 to 20 wanted where
loyalists and the rest were like i don't
care leave me alone i we have talked
about this in the past so we'll consider
that a correction because we had bad
numbers last time i said it was like 35.
10
no no i've heard crazy numbers people
say only 3 actually fought i see maybe
that's what it was but here's here's the
other thing too so first i'll point out
we're like
the the the average right now is 35
percent of the country across all party
lines and all places 35 would be in
favor of balkanizing i mean that's
massive
and that's up right so in in the south
the number i think in february was 50
now it's 66. so we are moving very very
quickly if we get to 40 or 45 of the
percent of the american people being
like we're done with this
my problem is it's this poll like we
were talking about this before the show
a little bit how many people were pulled
was it like a thousand people and three
hundred of them said i think it was two
thousand seven hundred something so
you've got like 600 people that said we
want to succeed and they're like 30 of
the country and it's like no that was
600 people but 2000 is enough to get a
representative sample 2 750. yeah well
that's more than enough you can get a
representative sample with the thousand
i think what it is is if what you said
about virtue signaling or people who are
partisan like if you didn't like biden
you're like i want to leave the country
but does that mean you actually want to
secede or does that mean you actually
want local autonomy because those are
two different things and for the midwest
point the reason why they're always torn
or swing voters is they're the reagan
democrats they're the people who align
with union politics who are against free
trade
but on social issues they align more
with the republican party this is why
you know reagan won you know i think in
the second election every state but
minnesota and you could correct me if
i'm wrong and eventually like those
became the swing states because reagan
was converting those voters who didn't
like the excesses from the democratic
party in the social movement but were
like mostly like working-class union
voters and that's who we're fighting
over now it's the same set of voters
that reagan flipped then
so like they're that's why i think the
independents are like i want to get out
of here because neither party is really
serving them in their opinion you were
correct i was minnesota um dc as well
but obviously it's not a state so but it
was just minnesota yeah um i i think
people are serious about balkanization
we saw there was that uh war game that
the dnc did it was heavily reported on
before the election where uh boston
globe uh reported john podesta what
what's his position he's like the chair
of the dnc or some high-ranking position
he was uh hillary's campaign manager
right yeah he he said if trump wins the
the western states should secede from
the union cal exit if you remember that
yeah but not just california also oregon
and washington and so when you see that
47 percent of democrats there according
to a representative sample which as you
said is more than enough 27 uh 2 750
that's a lot of people that sounds like
virtue signaling that podesta would say
that people should should succeed
because anyone private he didn't
publicly say it okay it was in a private
dnc war game that
some people who are witness to it talk
to some journalists
so podesta didn't come out and say hey
guys go do this privately he was like i
think this is what needs to happen and
then someone went to the journalists and
we're like yo this is what he's saying
not that i can trust any of these
journalists mind you for all i know john
podesta didn't say anything
but like what do you do when they lie
i've had i've had journalists
manufacture quotes from me yeah one guy
from i think it's the new yorker where
he took two different quotes and put
them together to make a different
sentence amazing or like half a quote
usually if you widen and out
ten words in either direction or 30
seconds in a clip and it changes
completely what they say then maybe
maybe you shouldn't be running with that
there's a clever way to get around
giving quotes to journalists when you
know they're going to try and pull some
bs and it's to add
like breaks
that are seemingly non-sequitur in your
sentence so like
if someone were to say what's your
favorite color i would say my tim poole
favorite color because i grew up in the
south side of chicago is actually and
this is because of my birthday green and
then what i have to do is they'll put my
dot dot favorite color dot dot dot and
it it makes it impossible so if you're
if you're trying to make sure they can't
pull things out of context you can add
things to it that forces them to put in
by doing that otherwise they can try and
break the sentence up and it looks
really weird in print when what they
usually do then is just do a paraphrase
like he expressed to me his favorite
color was green or something all right i
mean if you set it in audio they might
put your face if there's video over the
audio and just cut it together that the
way that they want it oh yeah yeah yeah
that's why i don't talk down talking on
the phone you know there's phones for
certain things but anyway back to uh the
vulcanization by the way
not gonna lead anything five percent in
his congressional run
let us never forget he was gonna show us
how progressives could win in purple
districts by the way but i i just i just
love how the shows that jen didn't
actually go to the website
like i i pulled up the article from
brightline watch to read the data so i
could do a segment about this and i did
it earlier on my on my tim cass channel
because i'm like what does it mean that
republicans want to secede the south
wants to succeed and i pull them like oh
it's actually
missing the bigger picture i guess if
you actually add all these up and
average it out it's a decent amount of
people so 35 might actually be relative
it might be incorrect because i'm i'm
adding up the totals and then dividing
it by the regions and it doesn't
necessarily represent how many people in
each region actually want to succeed so
the heartland i mean i think we need to
go by population density so i'm sure the
heartland doesn't have as many people as
the south the south probably has
substantially more people between
florida texas atlanta and then you look
at the the pacific which is alaska
california oregon and washington
probably a lot less people
so the percentages probably don't add up
properly the way i'm describing it in
fact it could be substantially more if
we actually go by population density and
did better math right i i would tend to
think that it would be less at least the
serious ones are definitely less i would
like to see
um like you ever seen like sam harris
break down the spheres of influence of
radicalization like that version of this
where it's like these people want to
leave but do they really just want local
autonomy
what's the difference i don't understand
what you mean well it's like uh the
states rights movements under under
obama like they would say that texas
should secede and break you know be its
own state or break up into five states
as it says in their constitution but in
reality they just wanted like the
governor to invoke more 10th amendment
stuff against obama and challenge what
he was doing which is similar to what
happened in california so how do you
know that's actually what they wanted
though well because i don't think when
push comes to shove these people would
actually vote in like a secessionist
party in their state i think they would
i think i think you often see that
regular people vote for the extreme
version of of these things because of
like especially right now as the
rhetoric is ramping up
i mean do they though because they voted
in biden in the primary and like he was
distinctly not extreme like in the
primary at least compared to who he's
talking to bernie who but what what did
the people say they wanted
well in polls they would say that like
in the top line polls this is why i
don't trust polling they would say that
they would want bernie sanders positions
in the top line polls but when you go
into the details you realize that they
think medicare for all is obamacare with
the public option which is actually
biden's position which is why when the
progressives were like we won on every
issue well so they voted for what they
wanted yeah
right so if an individual says they want
to secede they'd probably vote for it no
but that's the top line like that that
would be your i want medicare for all
but then when you ask them what what do
you think this actually means okay like
and you break it down like you're going
to get a wait you're going to get people
who just want states rights or autonomy
or maybe like an american federation
where they break up
some people want that but not right they
don't know what they're what they want
if they really like what is a succession
you attempt by military force to like
the american federal government will
come to fight you and kill people and
burn cities
to stop that state from seceding i don't
think they want that it's it's like if
you ever got into a fight with a
girlfriend and she's like i want to
break up with you
and then you're like okay okay let's
talk about this and then you talk about
and you realize she just wants you to
stop being a jerk like you know it it
comes down from that top-line aggressive
thing it is it is because if they start
saying that then you're like i you know
i'm gonna start taking you at your word
you gotta take them at their work oh
yeah
yeah i don't i don't i don't i don't
play games like that if someone came up
to me and they were like you know if
someone came up to me and said i'm going
to quit because i'm unhappy
it's great work with you what would
secession look like then if we could def
lay it out for people clearly like well
so so uh i think
civil war won't work in this regard
we're talking about five region
balkanization right
so i will say first and foremost joe
biden keeps talking about this being the
greatest threat since the civil war and
blah blah blah he's using the power of
the federal government to go after
trump's supporters and people they deem
to be extreme they're potentially i
guess it's now public they're compiling
lists of these people you know they're
going to be tracking the jackpot
reported it and there's some statements
about it so what would it look like well
there's there's
there is a lot of power in the federal
government but that power is derived
from the states and i don't mean that
figuratively like the states chose to
create the federal government like the
people who are in the federal government
are sent there are voted in
the the the the capitol police the
national guard the the power the federal
government has all across the country
from people who serve in the military
and the armed forces come from states so
what would happen if
somebody lives in say you know oregon
and they're as far left as they come and
they work in some kind of law
enforcement capacity and then
someone in the federal government says
something we want to do x we we need
your assistance but if if the country is
balkanizing they might say no i care i
care more about my state than i care
about going to dc to do whatever you
want or if balkanization is happening
and then someone in oregon is told like
we're going to be deploying you to texas
they're going to be like i got to stay
and defend oregon yeah so it's it's that
is a question of if we balkanize but
here's what i think is possible
if this sentiment
is this widespread 47 in the west makes
sense to me 33 of independence and 66
percent of republicans and 50 percent of
independents in the south that's crazy
and these are very heavily republic uh
uh
republican states
what i think actually could happen is
loss of confidence
in which case this is what i talked
about several times as to how i think a
civil war could actually happen not that
a bunch of states get together and say
we hereby declare good sir and start
gaining someone in congress but actually
what happens is a small town in oklahoma
puts up a roadblock and says not welcome
and then starts saying we're not going
to abide by these lockdowns or whatever
joe biden is saying and then the feds
have to come in and the people in
oklahoma say we are not letting you in
our town you have no you you have no
purchase here good sir look look look at
what what happens in like ohio where
they i think they arrested an atf agent
right those are exactly the kinds of
things that start happening now you have
second amendment sanctuaries popping up
and i think two-thirds of the counties
the united states
that is a is a break of confidence at a
at a growing scale so biden's freaking
out it's the greatest threat what the
republicans are doing uh because he
probably sees the federal government's
power is actually starting to dwindle
ohio recently some sheriff said we're no
longer going to be taking illegal
immigrants from ice why because they
send them here they tell us to hold them
and let them go into our towns no dice
it's not going to happen right the plans
they had not working so check this out
i'll tell you why i think joe biden's
panicking and i tell you why i think we
are inching closer towards this
the democratic base in this country is
is absolutely insane not like the
republicans are uh as a party are doing
much better but the democrats are split
dramatically from like moderate do
default democrats who don't really pay
attention to the fringe far left
the far left control more of the
manifesto for the democrats than the
moderates do who don't really pay
attention you can see this in the pew
research where the spike is actually
further left what does that mean
they tell joe biden we want open borders
we want total amnesty but joe biden
can't win on those positions so what
happens in office he says something like
okay we're gonna
stop trump's evil remaining mexico
policy
so now all the migrants come in it's
catching and release they get caught
they get released in the community now
you have children sleeping under bridges
in the dirt in mcallen texas because joe
biden needs to take actions the far left
wants but then can't actually deal with
the influx of migrants and migrant
children because the policy is insane it
makes no sense so what does he do
the bite administration has been
smuggling has been trafficking children
into other republican states under the
noses of the leadership of those states
the tennessee republicans freaked out
when the whistleblower came out with
this video footage showing that they
were using i guess now there's a
whistleblower talking to tucker carlson
saying there's an air for the texas air
force bases to take migrant kids and
traffic them to other states because
biden can't come out and say we're
turning the children away into the
desert because that was trump's policy
oh no he can't come out and say we're
gonna put these kids in the
concentration camps the democrats were
complaining about for five years
although they're doing that either
anyway so he's got to shuffle it under
the rug but eventually the republicans
in these red states find out about it
the sheriff in ohio finds out what
they're doing and these states are now
outraged the federal government is not
actually doing anything to serve the
people but is actively in a panic to
shuffle the problem under the rug while
actively refusing to solve the problem
in fact making the problem worse
you imagine biden keeps doing things
like that and you're going to see states
saying we will not comply okay okay so
that's like a good that's a lead up to
it but okay assuming that something
happens and then a state does secede
like let's just pick texas and i don't
know would it be organized would it be
six states at once would be one state
that goes first
that has a lot to do with if it would
succeed or not because if 49 states
seceded it would it would succeed if one
state tried it would probably fail
uh but what would it look like
we hereby declare we are you know our
sovereign court your two left brain on
this one
it doesn't need to be a bunch of guys in
suits walking in and saying ah hereby
declare it could literally just be that
a guy in texas stops taking the phone
calls of the federal government because
he doesn't care anymore because the the
the influence of the federal government
has been weakening so a law enforcement
officer looks at his phone and it says
ice and he goes i don't even care what
were you saying sir and then over time
it just breaks apart basically take over
a long period of time that would be
something like the governor sending
their own national guard to the border
in place of the federal government as an
example but like we've seen this before
under the obama administration sheriffs
were refusing this and i think the one
thing that would actually lead to a
potential civil war is something like
hyperinflation or extended inflation
because once the money starts becoming
less valuable that's when you get people
in the streets and everybody starts
panicking but to your point about the
immigration thing this is one of the
biggest mistakes the trump
administration made throughout its
entire time the reason they were putting
the kids in cages quote unquote was
because they wanted to deter children
from showing up to the border and the
trump administration as far as i know
never made the moral case for a harsh
policy on the border and we see what
happens when you're soft on that there's
kids that are being dumped over here
like i was at cpac i met guys that went
to the border and they showed me photos
of kids with disabilities that were just
literally jumped over the fence by
coyotes like they can't walk and they're
being dropped off because obama sent i'm
sorry biden
40 and slip right there sent the signal
to people i mean obama did the same
thing if you remember the unaccompanied
minor things pre uh trump but biden sent
the signal that if your kids come here
at least this is how it was translated
into latin america that if your kids
come here we'll take them which is worse
than saying if your families come here
we'll take them because now we have all
these kids going on this dangerous
journey seven thousand miles if you've
seen it they come up on these trains a
bunch of them fall off it's a disaster
you have to make the moral case for
strict enforcement and we're seeing this
across the country in not just
immigration policy but in san francisco
where they don't afford shoplifting
everything breaks down so what's
happening now florida is sending
troopers to texas to help secure the
border in south dakota saying i think
national guard
because the federal government isn't
doing it
lieutenant colonel allen west is running
to primary greg abbott because he says
abbott is waiting on permission from the
federal government to defend its own
border and he makes a really good point
abbott needs to take a stand
oh that was brutal
metaphorically yeah yeah also also
desantis is running for president that's
why he's sending the troopers like let's
let's be honest do you think so a
hundred percent oh okay
against trump though
i saw the cpac poll they did one with
trump and one without trump without
trump 58 yeah he's probably trying to
say hey buddy endorse me and i think
desantis would would in a lot of ways
probably be better way better because
and people are like you know oh they'll
smear him they'll attack him in the
media yeah but trump really boils
liberal blood you know desantis they're
gonna be like i don't know who that is
and i don't care you're not gonna be
able to rally people the same way well
desantis isn't gonna wake up shoot
himself in both feet and wonder why
there's blood all over the floor every
day like he's not gonna be tweeting
these disgusting horse faces yelling at
me on the internet nah he's you know
he's a bit more tactful but i will say
we've we've definitely seen some of this
under obama there was a period i i can't
remember when this was i think it may
have been under bush actually
where yeah actually i don't know maybe
it was obama we saw a wave of states
asserting sovereignty they were like
declaring that we are independent
sovereign and and retain our rights and
everything and it was like all they all
started doing it
10th amendment movement right
but i still i think that just shows the
escalation like if you a lot of people
say this all started with trump and then
so actually it started with obama
actually it started with bush well yeah
literally they're all connected there's
no like we're not in a vacuum it wasn't
like one day someone pressed like reset
on the country and then we all woke up
and said who should be the president
it's all connected going all the way
back since even probably the colonial
days yeah i think it tracks technologies
change because no longer do we have to
send a letter uh and send someone to go
ride a horse to washington dc to tell
them what i told them to tell them like
we have telephones and computers and we
can work these in this decentralized
manner the states can function in a more
we can decentralize power way easier
with modern technology and i think the
consciousness is now kind of
showing that but it's coming out as you
know secession what it's this is more of
a decentralization i'll tell you what
the problem is it's the absolutism of
the democratic party and the inability
of conservatives or should say of the
republicans and many conservatives to
assert themselves on things so i'll
explain what that means the democrats
demand absolute law so they say we
should ban these guns
and then you're like dude i live in west
virginia we've got like coyotes and
bears and stuff like come on you can't
you know i mean and also i hunt i live
in the middle of nowhere i'm not you're
not worried about this stuff you live in
a different place
it makes no sense a lot of the things
the democrats advocate for because how
it affects
the other half of the country who don't
live in cities but they demand that
absolute law if the city is negatively
impacted everyone in the country must be
must be under the same law republicans
don't come out and say we demand x they
say no wait don't
speed bumps for the democrats yeah over
a long enough period of time the
democrats keep passing laws that are
favorable for cities well probably not
even favorable for cities but designed
to be favorable or i'm sorry they're
designed to appear favorable to cities
although whether or not they actually
work i think most the time they don't
and then rural people get negatively
impacted by it but but what percentage
of the democrats is it because i just
had the new york city democratic primary
and they elected the cop
who wants to bring back stop and frisk
and the anti-crime unit which is
horribly named because the police are
all anti-crime it should be called the
anti-shooting unit but they elected the
tough on crime cop and he won in the
first round of voting and when they did
the ranked choice and they did that he
finally got over the top maya wiley the
bill de blasio woman who literally her
campaign was like i'm a black woman vote
for me i'm progressive never did
anything in her life except serve as a
counselor for bill de blasio like she
she did worse when they ranked it up
like she was the second place which is
horrible and i'm ashamed of my city but
it's the democrats what are you gonna do
but adam's not only one but he won
uh with minorities like he got 45 to 75
of the vote in all the majority uh black
or hispanic areas that's how he won but
think about how amazing it is that he
still is he still wants to confiscate
guns he's still very much you know
except for him he can have a gun right
exactly so he very much is just
he's still a democrat and so we're like
but he is pro cop like think about that
logic where it's like well at least he
doesn't want to completely abolish the
police
he's still he's still bad on a lot of
these things but true but like giuliani
was a gun grabber as mayor of new york
city michael bloomberg was a gun grabber
and a nanny stater like he didn't want
you to have a big soda
so yeah right but i always say new york
is different so like as much as i want
to say oh the democrats are different
the reason new york city is different
and you've been to new york city is
because everybody rides the subway and
everybody walks on the streets so
democrats actually have to live with the
policies that they advocate for there
they can't escape out into the burbs
that's why we get tough on crime mayors
and that's why i had faith in new york
city and i said that this election would
determine whether or not i would
consider moving or not
because we we actually do vote tough on
crime it's it's not chicago it's not
baltimore which i drove through today
and then what happens is because
they're actually not tough on crime the
extremists then protest the democrats
own policies
they go around and they constantly
obstruct the streets they protest they
new york's not a big riot place but it
never ends and then that turns into a
national movement so because people like
uh you know uh eric adams right yeah
because he's like
they call him tough on crime by new york
standards no no he's he's legit he's
like i'm going to bring back stop and
frisk like the republicans weren't like
we're going to bring back stop at first
he's like no no we're going to shake
down people right this is some skulls
that's the problem you see what happens
is then black lives matter comes out and
turns that local problem from democrats
into a national problem and then demands
everyone in the country live by this
ideology and because they have such
influence in national level
communications politics marketing and
corporations because new york is a hub
for that
some random dude in in in west virginia
who lives in the mountains next to his
you know his brother cletus who's
actually 20 miles away has to have new
laws on his guns because of the failures
of new york democrats and it's not
necessarily just er it's not like it's
eric adams fault it's that the people
who live in these cities continually
elect the same kind of people who do
very similar things with very similar
policies that don't work well i mean you
you're you're right to a certain extent
because i mean new york city distinctly
banned chokeholds but after george floyd
died from a maneuver that would have
been illegal for an nypd officer we
still cut a billion dollars out of our
police because we had to solve the
problem of minneapolis's policing issue
people in london are protesting over
jordan's floor hands up don't shoot
which michael brown didn't have his
hands up and the london police don't
carry guns yep
yeah so so what's happening is you have
this
you know ian mentioned it's technology
it's the internet's communications it's
not about any of the policy it is
literally my tribe must win at all costs
and we will demand power and and i'll
tell you i want to talk about story work
it's really really weird this is a sign
this story right here is assigned to me
of the uh of the collapse it's a very
slow collapse the first thing i'll say
all right i'll give you i'll give you
the story boston pride
lgbt pride dissolves amid diversity
complaints an organization that's been
around for 50 years to advocate for lgbt
rights has dissolved because
black lives matter activists said that
they didn't have enough diversity on
their board now i want to mention
something i say it's a slow collapse
right
we went to a diner today to pick up some
petty melts we got everybody these
burgers are so good oh they were good
they were they were delicious and a
peanut butter pie and there's a sign on
the door and this this shocked me it
said for something like forgive us from
now on we'll be operating only 6am to
5pm
as we attempt to rectify our staffing
shortages
half the diner was closed like they had
the signs up like you can't sit here and
they were completely understaffed and
they a diner that closes at 5pm
nothing to do with pride or whatever but
it's just like
the food shortages
the chaos
yeah the unemployment stuff it's just
getting worse and worse and worse we'll
come back to that i want to mention as
part of the slow collapse but look at
this story they say this decision was
made with a heavy heart out of love and
hope for a better future the
organization's board said in a statement
boston pride the organization that has
organized the city's pride celebrations
for 50 years has announced it's shutting
down
the dissolution announced friday
afternoon and a statement on the group's
website comes after the reportedly
all-white board of directors had faced
ongoing accusations of ignoring racial
minorities and transgender people it is
clear to us that our community needs and
wants change without the involvement of
boston pride
here's what here's the quote we have
heard
i'm gonna read the quote okay
we have heard the concerns of the
q-t-b-i-p-o-c community what and others
the statement continued i
i don't know what that means and i'm not
trying to be mean to the
quit the puck
oh cute bipod is that what supposed to
be
i don't i don't i don't i don't look
these people are increasingly
there was a video i saw of this like
young woman and she was it's a viral
tic-tac where she's like you can use new
words for your non-binary parents like
zizo and zorda i'm not kidding she was
like pom pom
peanu
dofi and i'm like you're just saying
gibberish words what are you doing
that's where we're at right now these
young people are like i can make up a
thing
and so they make up a thing and then the
people who make up a thing go to the
established thing and say you have to
shut down because we made a thing up and
they go okay and then it shuts down how
do we function as a society look i'm
sure there's a bunch of conservatives
you know cracking cigars and laughing
you know watching this but i'm like
boston pride 50 years of fighting for
lgbt rights and quite successfully and
now they're shut down just like that
like occupy wall street that was my
experience at occupy i went and i
brought the constitution i was like yo
i'm going to tell people about the
federal reserve this is having a rally
of troops and when i went up the girl
was like uh i was going to go speak to
them to like that some news organization
and the girl was like no we've already
had too many white people speak to the
news i was like what i'm about to blow
people's minds dude let me add it and
they wouldn't so i was like well too
much too much racism for good stuff at
the top you know
it's just it's just demands for power
man
and the fed
long live the ron paul revolution that's
what we're up to man repeal the federal
reserve act of 1913. um
for
the polarization among the left is
ridiculous their their desire to
fraction off into little pieces is crazy
especially because i always thought and
i could be wrong about this but i'm
going to pretend like it's authoritative
the rainbow flag was like all colors can
be uh within the lgbt community if
that's not real it sounds like it makes
sense and they should adopt that
but yeah um there's a desire among
lefties to do what i think thomas will
refer to as like mascotism like they
want to have black mascots right that
aren't necessarily like they don't
necessarily have anything to do with the
organization but as long as they're
there
and it looks nice and it's
weirdly to give the illusion of fighting
racism but in reality there's like
nothing more racist than like i want
a black logo tokenism yeah so that you
can you can uh you know think i'm
virtuous you know i i will say uh i'm
actually surprised they did this but
they did add a white stripe to the to
the new to the new uh uh lgbt flag so
but what what is the white stripe for
though white people really
i would doubt i would don't though i
mean i look at a flag that's got a black
and a brown stripe for black and brown
people and there's a white stripe and
then a yellow triangle the only thing i
can say is if they say the stripes
represent the color of the people well
it's a white stripe i was either they're
like life is not black and white ian you
know that flag is copyrighted right that
new one really yeah it's owned by
somebody you mean the one with the the
purple circle in it yeah uh i don't know
if it's a circle but it's like the one
with the black and brown with the
diamond it looks like the rip off
yeah yeah i think my biggest problem is
the level of intelligence of the people
that we're talking about because people
are not black and white
at all and we never have been but
that people are just accepting these
dumb phrases of black and white and then
they're saying it anyway is concerning
to me my favorite thing about the whole
critical race theory stuff the the
critical race applied principles is that
they're like whiteness doesn't mean
white people we're not saying it's
whiteness it's a structure of of this
system
black and brown means literally the
color of your skin yeah it's like
black there's no black skin it's like
clearly they mean white people when
they're saying whiteness
well it's it you always got to like get
these people and ask them okay what's
the difference between a white
supremacist nation and a white majority
nation like they won't be able to tell
you and i didn't think of that i got
that question from devin tracy well
here's a question what's the difference
between a white supremacist nation and a
chinese majority nation
well they would be because chinese
supremacists well exactly like but they
would say whiteness they would say oh
well i kid you not they would say
something like well because the chinese
population is the majority in china
they're white
i mean they think asian people are white
anyway so but yeah but i i will say it's
just
this this this flag in my opinion
represents that
there was no committee vote on this it
was like someone did it and it was a
meme and that shows that a lot of what's
happening on the left is basically
i view it as kind of like the oh you
ever see that horror movie the blob
yeah yeah a long time ago which one uh
there was one it was like in the 80s i
think that's the one
yeah
yeah like it lands in the media or
something yeah and then it's like it's
small but then it eats some something a
rodent then it grows a little bigger
that's exactly what it is right that's
what the left is doing right now it's
just absorbing institutions and then
growing bigger but it's nonsensical it's
just a heaping mass you can see it it's
non-descript and it's insane
then it's ripping itself
well it's ripping everything apart it's
just destroying things and and it's
based on nonsense like the the the whole
thing about black trans women being
killed more
uh my friend nuestra did a video on this
and he found that black trans women have
a lower rate of death by homicide than
regular uh black men like so biological
males that just identify as male 1 yeah
yeah over explaining that
you did a good job so so i want to i
want to just kind of wrap this into the
conversation
at large is that we're talking about we
start off talking about the
balkanization of this country
why is it possible in my opinion that
we're heading towards this because this
stuff makes no sense boston pride shuts
down
because black lives matter accuse them
of not having enough diversity so they
just shut down their civil rights
organization after 50 years just like
that bro if it's that easy to dissolve
an organization and we're at you know a
roughly 35 percent probably not a fair
number but you know it's the best number
we got
how do you how hard do you think it's
really going to be to dissolve these
bonds they they did that on toronto
remember too a couple years ago they sat
down in front of the
right and then they gave them a list of
demands where i come from that's called
taking hostages they had a huge
acronym that i tried trying to read i'm
not kidding it was like um
it was like qti three nine
like i'm i'm not trying to be mean i'm
like literally number two in it so yeah
yeah but no no i'm not so there's lgbtqi
uh lgbtq
iap2a yeah there's a plus no but there's
another one which is a reference to
marginalized people not
uh like the lgbt one is a reference to
like i gender identities and sexuality
and the other one is based on racial
identities and you know raci and culture
so that one is like
you know you know they do like um
what is it uh asian pacific islander or
whatever it's called api or whatever api
or whatever yeah there was one like that
and it was like aapi t3
s2911 that's like a robot's name t2 was
a way better movie than t3 i'm just
throwing out that controversial opinion
no no but it is it gets crazy my
favorite one that's included in there
isn't the two spirit it's the second a
for ally it's like one that's just yeah
there's one of them is ally so if you're
a straight
and a straight yeah a straight a
straight and a a cis heteronormative oh
i was thinking about cis and trans
there's trans out the romans had trans
alpine gaul and cis alpine gaul i don't
know if that's relevant and says are
means beyond and nearer to the literally
literally why they say you're a cis
person or a trans person they say this
is a reference to like i'm glad that you
know that i got that out but like if
you're straight then like you get to be
in the in the acronym and it's like dude
that's not for you just stop go get out
of there like i added a white stripe to
the flag we still don't know what it's
for it doesn't matter what they say it's
for if the black and brown represent
black and brown people the white stripe
represents white people is the white
stripe underneath the black and brown
stripe no it's underneath the blue and
right that makes sense look at this
picture that maybe what is this called
that may be white i just like that
if it's above it i'm just going to say
that um well it is the first stripe
racism
yeah
yeah
i um
the whites are going to be asexual
no the um
isn't that the what the yellow is for
what is the yellow no i'm not going to
say what i thought the yellow was for
because that was a bad answer super
racist i think they're missing the point
of white i was going to say pikachu like
the pokemon when i so my family had a
cafe in uh on north halsted in chicago
which is like this it's boys town it's
the gay neighborhood and then there's um
the one where jesse smaller was attacked
no no he wasn't there he was in uh he
was in downtown okay north halstead is
several miles north it's um
it's by wrigley field and then there's
there's boys town in ladies town and i
forgot what ladies town's actual name is
but that's where the lesbians are at and
then the gay men are in in boys town but
i was told uh when i was there that the
flag represented different aspects of
the of the gay community not races or
anything like that i don't know for sure
though but it's weird to see that they
added race too i thought it was just
like flamboyant colors that they liked
wearing no they were colors they
represent something right they represent
something i thought it was them being
extra because normally one cause one
color and they're like we want all the
colors
to me like deal with gray if you want to
be opposed to us i don't like the whites
on there because when you look at a
rainbow all the colors it's white light
and only if you look at it through a
prism do you start to see all the colors
of the rainbow which is the flag is the
colors of the rainbow so when they
combined all of the lantern rings they
created the white lantern core
there we go there's all the lights
proving my points
i'm just saying like the new flags got a
white stripe in it now man i think of
myself as an ally i think of myself as
like an allied to people in general to
these people of all kinds but i don't
virtue signal would you ally with the
blob
let me put it this way the blob consumes
a krispy kreme i think that would be and
you like krispy kreme and you're like
i'm a fan of the blob because it
consumed christmas it's a game time
decision because if if
no i probably wouldn't allow the blob
that's what i'm trying to say um i
believe in civil rights i'm fairly i'm
i'm actually fairly
moderately left on a lot of the social
justice causes but when you have a blob
that consumes institutions i'm not going
to pretend the blob represents the blob
is full of people so you can no they
dissolve you interact with those people
well
i i would say you can't use their
language like the the reason they use
the term like social justice and which
is why i need my channel to be the
opposite of that is because it's like oh
i'm not against societal progress and
justice but like once we start adopting
their language it doesn't work i agree
with you i'm like in terms of social
issues i'm really libertarian but like
we can't we can't use their terms yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know that's that's
absolutely so so just to simplify when
the blob when i see like you know an
lgbt lgbt you know uh pride campaign or
something or boston pride and they're
like we believe that we should have the
right to to live freely and be in our
homes i'm like i hear you man then a
blob consumes them and then the blob
like a face comes out of the flesh of
the blob but it's like just like a flat
blob face going i believe it i'm like
that's not boston pride that's something
else i knew you once yeah remember a
little longer have you ever seen uh the
frighteners oh with um michael uh
michael j fox nope you never seen it oh
i've heard of it though there's like the
the walls like it's like someone's
pushing out through like latex that's
what it looks like that's what it would
be like when the when the when the blob
is rolling by and then you see like you
know a civil rights activist come on go
support
they can be exercised from the blob it
just takes strategic uh surgery mental
surgery
it's also weird how these movements kind
of imitate real life because there is
more homophobia among like the black
community in the united states of
america on average obviously there's
pockets of like you know evangelical
christians or or actually mormons are
nice to everybody they just want to play
board games with you but there's like
pockets of it so like for a like
supposed black civil rights movement to
bully out of existence a gay civil
rights movement it's really
like it's it's like almost like the
movements are imitating their uh their
base well let's let's jump back to the
the nightmare scenario that is what the
government is doing and uh outside of
the the insanity of the left so so the
general idea i guess like the reason i
wanted to get into that is that you've
got this cultural movement which is just
chaos it's fire it's rot it's
destructive and you can see that at the
federal level i feel like they really
really are panicking this idea of
balkanization is real when the states
start saying f you when they were like
yo we're gonna lock down and taxes in
florida are like nah joe biden said we
we're gonna have to lock down more
meanwhile people are pardoning it up in
some of these states clearly having no
authority check out this story from the
new york post
the white house is flagging posts for
facebook to censor over covet
misinformation we also saw that story
where the blind administration and the
dnc were talking with text message
providers phone companies to censor text
messages
oh we crossed that rubicon baby
this is it that's
no no no we haven't crossed the roof bro
what happened
can go on tv and say she emphasized the
word for she goes we are flagging for
facebook i was like whoa
that's not constitutional in any stretch
of the imagination
when they would normally do something
like this they would go we are not
telling facebook what to do we are
merely asking them to enforce their
rules to help this country even that is
questionable the government can't go to
a private company and say censor this
they can't she's
saying they're doing it they talk about
going after our text messages bro that
rubicon's been crossed so who's caesar
in this metaphor joe biden no
no one would follow him into battle
come on man hairy legs nobody's gone
both caesar and brutus
i think the wonderful thing is there's
no cult of personality here if there was
a cult leader democratic president that
people were obsessed with we might we
might see a trump yeah but he wasn't the
best democratic leader like if there was
a democrat if biden was not biden but
some yeah crazy cult
leader we would have that would be
rubicon danger where he could turn it
into an empire we have a we have a very
strong first amendment so when you do
stuff like this that's not technically a
formal attack on the first amendment
that's referred to as chilling free
speech and you're not allowed via
supreme court decisions to chill free
speech in that way i i don't know i
think this is overt
like
they're not saying they're not saying
we're going to censor it they're trying
to do an end around to censor indirectly
so like that's the maneuver that they
would be using but that's that's also
unconstitutional it's called
free speech no i think chilling free
speech is different i'm pretty sure
um if the the government uh democrats
are being sued over this in california
if the government goes to a private
company and says censor this it is the
government taking an overt action not
chilling they're literally the ones
doing the sensory the way that you
phrased it it was like we're not saying
censor it but we're flagging this for
facebook no no no i'm saying
normally what the democrats or the
government would do is say the
government is not in the business of
censoring americans right we're just
letting facebook know when there's
misinformation and they can deal with it
as they see fit that's not what they're
doing right that's what you'd expect
them to do what they're doing now is
saki is literally saying we are flagging
it for them to remove okay so that's
that's what i that's right that's that's
overtly
it would be like this imagine if the
federal government was like
we hired uh um uh securitas to go uh uh
uh
detain a bun arrest a bunch of people
who are at church
because they're christian
you're not gonna be like uh that that
that's okay because a private company
did it well the government hires them to
do it the government instructs them to
do it
you they can't that's literally what
they're doing right now this is this is
like the
or maybe it will lead to the official
return of operation chokepoint which was
under the obama administration where
they would target certain sketchy
borderline industries
and reach out to the banking companies
and payment processes and all that and
get them to stop doing business with
them and the whole point was like we're
going to do human trafficking but then
all of a sudden people who were like
legitimately actors in the porn industry
would lose their bank accounts right
they're like we're going to do gun
smuggling but all of a sudden federally
licensed firearm dealerships would lose
their bank accounts so like the obama
administration in well not formally
created a list of industries and like
industries that they det determined to
be adjacent to problems in the country
and they use federal power to get rid of
that then trump comes into office and
these companies almost continue that
program in his absence and now biden's
back and he's like well let's formalize
what you guys have been doing already
here's what's next
glenn greenwald tweets the white house
is admitting that their compiling lists
of people who they claim are posting
content they regard as problematic and
that constitute misinformation and are
demanding facebook remove them this is
authoritarianism
so how long until the white house puts
out their list of extremists content
producers and they say the
insurrectionists were following these
people which of course can include most
of the people you you know and love
because people follow a lot of people i
you know you know what they won't do
they won't point out that many of these
same people will be following brian
stelter on cnn well but that's not
relevant but you'll see crowder's name
in there you know stixx and hammer was
like i hope i make the list what happens
when they do that and then they say
the the extremists those who espouse
incitement to insurrection that is
illegal and we're going to shut down
their accounts
yeah i mean look i was told by one of
these quote-unquote insurrectionists
that never went into the building that
they watch my content so like oh i
inspired an extremist i i somehow may
have inspired somebody that's further to
the right than me much further according
to
to this like interpretation but yeah
it's definitely a huge problem that
they're that they're doing this and that
they keep pushing the gas on censorship
again it's it's an informal or i'm sorry
it's the formalization of what was
already happening while trump was in
office what became normal and like the
buy administration is totally cool with
it and we're not we shouldn't be
surprised because remember when obama
played the facebook algorithm the
facebook guys came up to him after he
won his election and they were like we
knew what you were doing and we thought
it was so cool because we were on your
side yeah trump plays the facebook
algorithm they changed the rules
completely read it yeah right the the
donald dominated the front page about it
all the time so they were like we're
going to remove the donald from the
front page period as soon as republicans
figured out how to use the internet they
were like well you know we got to have
authoritative services so what if 95 of
the mainstream media except for foxes
it's left-leaning don't worry about it
it's going to be authoritative and now
they're untethered
the left is completely untethered from
society because
of
once big tech started playing that game
of we can will ban the conservatives and
that's literally what they're doing
there are some people on the left who
get banned don't get me wrong there's a
lot of them
but when people saw and i don't think it
was it was an intentional movement i
think it was a natural progression that
you've you've got left and right and
facebook and twitter and youtube say
this chunk of the right is gone
and this chunk of the left is gone now
the whole overton window just went and
shifted farther left
you get the rainbow bleep bleep monkey
it can actually i think you can say butt
rainbow bleep butt monkey that's very
interesting because physically if you
had um a structure of two two pieces and
you removed one of them like the far the
far right you said was removed that
would
release the scent like you said it
actually said untethered like it's
you've removed the counterweight exactly
exactly another way to put it is if
you're if if your left finger tips get
get removed in an accident but your
whole right hand has removed an accident
and you're right-handed now you're going
to be left-handed you can still use your
right arm for things providing support
but all of a sudden now everything's
going to shift to the left where the
resources are so so long as the
censorship is 80 percent conservative
and 20 left
everything's going to shift to the left
because it's untethered there's nothing
holding them back anymore so what do you
get
drag queen story hour
because they don't care about what what
republicans say because you will get
banned for criticizing these communities
if you say what your issue with it is
you're banned
then it levels up now you've got rainbow
bleep butt monkey showing up at the
library and the parents going what and
screaming and freaking out anatomically
correct someone put on
yeah we can't i won't talk too much
about it but they walk that back in the
uk for you know the next couple months
they're never going to do anything like
that again but the drag queen story hour
i've been on this for years because i do
a partnership with the david horowitz
freedom center right and
that's not just in public libraries in
certain districts in this country that's
in our public schools so if you pay
taxes you're paying for drag queen story
hour for these people to come to your
school read to your kids and all the
books are about how like you know you
should probably think about gender
transitioning like kindergartner have
you ever considered this do you uh
you ever been to a strip club
yes
ian yeah lydia no i have not but but i
was there because i knew somebody that
owned it
so
what a lot of people don't know is that
in many states maybe even most they
don't get fully nude in fact in many of
these lame yeah that's true though
topless only with if you have alcohol
you can't have full nude a lot of times
with alcohol in a lot of states and
especially a lot of reds
how are they still in business with the
internet i'm just questioning people
like to be there physically yeah but the
other thing too is some places aren't
even topless
some states don't even allow topless so
you ask someone what is it stripping and
they're going to assume full nude that's
actually not true that's actually not
true there are places sure just when
they take off the beanie yes then here's
the point
if you went to say i don't know
jankyuger of the young turks
and asked them if they would support
children
taking off their clothes on stage as
adult men
would you support an 11 year old boy on
stage taking off his clothing while
adult men gave money to him every time
he did
no of course the boy was still wearing
shorts and a t-shirt underneath his
outfit but it was pulling off the
clothes and then getting money do you
think they would support that i actually
think right now they wouldn't give you a
straight answer because they'd be like
what are you talking about
what are you trying to say i don't trust
what you're asking it's a
straightforward question the point is
chantky actually defended
child stripping i'm not exaggerating
this is not hyperbole there is i'm not
going to say the name of the child who
does what they call drag shows but drag
shows are conspicuously similar to
stripping where he he goes on the stage
as a bunch of adults throw money to him
and give give him money as he takes his
clothing off and so i saw that
and i immediately was like now that
looks like stripping
called some people i knew
who worked in the industry asked them
some questions and they said i i didn't
ask them about the drag show i said what
would you call this and i said a person
on stage taking off an outer layer of
clothing to reveal
undergarments maybe a t-shirt and shorts
while adults in the audience are giving
money as they do it and they were like
that's stripping and i said
in in that as i described it like of
course and i was like they don't get
naked
but you don't always get naked i'm like
okay so that would be stripping yes
absolutely these these are people i know
who have who have worked in some women
in multiple states and they explain in
they're like in vegas here's how it
works vegas is like they got brawls in
in like the dakotas it's actually like
this in in red states that are more
religious oh man you can't even you have
to be wearing like a full top
so quite literally it's
indistinguishable and jankyuger has a
show where he actively defends the
practice
so
when we're at that level
i don't know i don't know what to say
man that that is untethered that that is
what untethered means that was like a
handmaker to my face i saw that
high-profile progressive youtube channel
with millions of followers and he
actively says
pre-pubescent boys taking off their
clothing for adult men at a bar for
money is okay i'm like what
no i'm sorry dude you've crossed the
line you're untethered from reality
because i can sit here and be like i
actually think we need basic universal
healthcare with private supplemental
insurance i'm in favor of that i'm
actually in favor of universal parental
leave i think we've got a big problem
with parents not being there for their
kids i think if we had if we had that
some way solidify would be fantastic i
think we got a huge problem that
businesses are tied to healthcare i
think andrew yang was right about that
and uh i think the young turks have lost
their minds when they defend child child
stripping yeah
well i mean you better stop attacking
jank otherwise anna's gonna blackmail
you but um
but uh yeah no uh jenk
saying that is ridiculous and they are
very like weasley about it because
they'll deny it but then they'll say how
they're in favor of it like that's the
trick they're like that's not happening
but also you're weird and creepy for
being against it even though
even even under drag circumstances so i
i asked around typically they leave the
money for whichever drag person is on
the stage in like a jar away from that
so you're not throwing them yeah you
don't have the image of them flinging
dollar bills up there and that's not
even just a kid on a stage getting that
image it's also like after midnight yeah
like what are you doing it was without
those i'm pretty sure they were drinking
right
i don't wanna i don't wanna say things
unless i'm absolutely sure so either way
it's it's untethered so what happens is
when you have a tribalism the blob it's
absorbing institutions and now the blob
is saying that these things should
happen which are horrifying it's
disgusting
jenk is scared that if he says the wrong
thing he'll offend his audience so he
defends it and they had jordan klepper
from comedy central saying isn't it so
great to hear what this this kid has to
say about being an advocate and i'm like
you people are nuts
you've gone so far off the rails it used
to be
you know when i grew up
that the conservatives would argue
something and it was an argument no no
you can't do that safe legal and rare
for abortion
now it's
lena dunham saying she wish she got an
abortion or whatever or whatever she
said
yeah things like that they've untethered
i've seen jen get bullied too he in the
beginning when defunded the police was
becoming popular jake was smart he was
like this is a stupid slogan and you
know 80 percent of people are against
defunding the police but slowly but
surely because his audience is supposed
to be like more on the left he started
saying listed i'm gonna be this defund
the police guy and now every time he
talks about it he's like we're in four
defund the police and then it's like a
30-second explanation he's for it but
then he gives you like the 45 minute
pitch of why that doesn't actually mean
defund the police he was right the first
time defund the police is a stupid
slogan i wish i would have invented it
for the democrats to use because it's
tanking them across the country but
yeah like so i've seen him get bullied
by his audience so this might be an
issue where he's like that's
questionable but over time it got he got
browbeat by his audience the most
fascinating thing now that i see with
the young turks is jenks insistence that
the alt left exists and what does that
mean glenn greenwald michael tracy aaron
mattei and jimmy dore
the alt left
i love it that's not what alt left means
it's not what it ever meant and it never
really caught on anyway so it's funny
that he tries claiming
that the the people who criticize the
establishment and his fake progressive
movement are alt-right and alt-left it's
like dude maybe you've just lost the
plot because you're chasing the dragon
man you want the ratings you want the
clicks
you look at the supercuts of the young
turks over the years
and it's really it's really you can
really see how they've compromised over
and over and over again i saw uh a clip
of them from they had the new hire and
she was like three days on and he was
like what career you don't have do you
ever see that oh kim horticulture he
kind of and he he as you tell
immediately he felt horrible about it
but he was so chill back then he was so
much more relaxed he's so like
agitated things have like tweaked him
out over the last like six years i
totally get it i do
we talked about this we talked about
this the other day man this is important
i
uh you know when i got started in more
actively publicly in politics like
occupy wall street i went to occupy wall
street because i saw these videos of
police like it's just dragging a guy by
his foot and it's like his hands
bleeding
but i also knew
a bunch of hackers because i had been
hanging out hacker spaces in los angeles
i knew a bunch of hackers you know
around the world actually because i you
know made some friends got some
connections these all were on the left
all the hacking community was on the
left anti-establishment anti-fed
anti-intelligence agencies they were
pro-journalists pro-information pro-free
speech
and then something changed
a bunch of these hackers all of a sudden
became authoritarian and pro-fbi in fact
some of the some of these people are on
were on facebook cheering for the fbi
raid on giuliani
and i commented on the post saying i'm
so glad to see you finally been
de-radicalized that you would now
actively support the fbi and they're
like well i mean
well they're they're doing the right
thing now
dude
these people on the left used to laugh
about the trolling that weave would do
i can't even say the name of weave's
organization i cannot say some of the
things he's done one of the most
notorious trolls if not the most
notorious troll on the internet saying
the most offensive things
a bunch of people on the left
recognized the right of free speech
and they were edgy and they were fun and
they mocked things and they made jokes
and you had george carlin and george
carlin would say all of the racial slurs
in the world in his bit
then something started to change over
the past 10 years rapidly and quickly
where for whatever reason the leftists
fell in line so imagine your gent jugger
and you're watching the transformation
of your audience
i gotta be honest i i i the last time i
saw uh jen we got he yelled at me
because he was losing it before that i
was shaking his hands at vidcon so only
like probably three
three and a half years ago maybe talking
to him about ad rates and youtube and
then he started to lose it because like
you said initially he's like defund the
place is wrong and now he's embracing it
the left has dramatically changed and i
think there's one really easy and
obvious reason
young people
who are authoritarian and pro-state were
growing up
entering the the public left the the the
political left and influencing what was
being said and so now all of the
prominent establishment leftists had to
start falling in line with their
changing audience
so they embrace all that stuff
i've seen some sad stories i'm not gonna
get into full details but i know some
people who
i'm not gonna get into full details i
know some people who have gone through
severe depression i mean you you live
with these people you're friends with
them for for ten years
you've gone through all these adventures
you've said every awful thing you can
think of because you're trolls on the
internet hackers who believe in free
speech and then one day all of your
friends are saying you can't say that
anymore everything you've done is wrong
and we're going to cancel you unless you
come out in support of us and then
you're thinking to yourself like
these people don't believe in anything
we've done they hate who we are they
hate what we've done what do you do
so
losing his mind freaking out snapping at
me at politicon
yeah he's trapped he is trapped in that
box
also it's frustrating if you're like the
network
and you see all this talent come through
your system and then they can go be more
successful on your own and you're seeing
your numbers drop but your former
employees doing well dave rubin i've
done videos about how anna and jank have
been unbelievably nasty to dave rubin
talking about how like they never liked
him they wanted to hire his husband and
they like embarrassed him it's really
nasty stuff that you should never air
publicly jimmy dore the only difference
with the jimmy dore thing is jimmy dore
is using jank's rhetoric more
effectively jank's the big money and
politics guy he'll tell you if you take
five grand as a congressman from from
the nra then you're corrupt and you want
children to die by firearms well jenk
took 20 million dollars from jeffrey
katzenberg so when jimmy dore points
that out everything jank has been saying
up until this time
it jimmy has a rhetorical advantage and
it's like yeah you shouldn't put all
your eggs in the money in politics
basket what we're seeing with the
meltdown of the young turks is it's
exactly what you were saying
it's funny that you have these people
who are all part of the network in some
way and they move on and find huge
success
jimmy dore is still very much saying
what he's always said he's critical of
the establishment he's critical of
democrats and and glenn greenwald as
well i i i remember i criticized glenn
greenwald because i thought he was being
unfair to cnn because he did it he was
doing this at this event and he was
talking about cnn and i was like come on
like you know we can rag on the
mainstream media but yo hold on there a
minute
now i look at a lot of things they're
doing and i've got my criticisms of
glenn greenwald absolutely but i'm
impressed that he stuck stuck to his
principles for as long as he did to the
point where he actually leaves the
intercept
jan kyuger is watching that he's
watching the people that used to
represent
the people that do represent his values
what he actually believes done inside
but he knows he can't do anything
because he's tethered to this contract
here's what i think 20 million who do
you take it from uh jeffrey katzenberg
so he can't just come out and say the
things he wants to say because he he has
contracts he's locked in places
katzenberg the disney guy yeah a former
disney ceo yeah big hillary clinton
bundlers imagine you have a contract
that's like you gotta do x y and z
and they're like don't worry we're all
about the the left and progresses right
and you're like this works you sign the
deal
then the progressives become
authoritarian crackpot ideologues and
you're looking at former employees
leaving
and your ship is sailing and you're like
i literally can't get off the boat
because of the contract i signed so are
they stuck under like a contract it's an
investment so like the fact that they're
not profitable like you know you have to
you have to make a return for your
investors it's not like they bought the
i'm sure they bought a portion of it you
don't give somebody 20 million dollars
for no right zero percent of their
company but uh but you know it's a
private company so a lot of the details
are are hidden but yeah it's it's that
but and what's funny about glenn
greenwald and jimmy dore being anti-jank
is that jank jimmy dore and greenwald
were all a part of the crew that tried
to kick sam harris out of the left years
ago
so like these are like so when you're
saying glenn greenwald was unfair like
not cnn to sam harris yeah unbelievably
unfair i'm jimmy dore too and jimmy dore
like
even though i'm enjoying this
like i'm not a jimmy dore fan and i i
can't stand people in my audience so hi
guys
jimmy dore's the correct leftist jimmy
dore's the good leftist like let me be
100 clear about something have you ever
heard the this this idea that um the
young turks inspired a police shooting
i've never heard that before yeah so
it's it's the baton rouge one i won't
name the name for the algorithm purposes
the young turk that inspired them was
jimmy dore i do remember hearing about
this vaguely and you can find the videos
online so like for me
like it's a battle of the scummy i will
watch it for entertainment but i'm not
i'm not jumping on anything i like jimmy
dore for one reason
he's he'll talk to you he'll be straight
about it
so he has his opinions he makes his
videos he talks about we want to talk
about i disagree with him on a decent
amount but i know that i can message him
and he'll he's like a real human being
and so i i know a lot of people ian and
i have differing opinions but if we can
actually talk and you'll be honest and
in your in our conversations like real
people then i'm cool with that like i i
could hang out with a communist so long
as they were totally honest about what
communism was and meant just don't lie
to me and be real and i'll be like well
maybe we shouldn't maybe we won't be
friends but i can have a polite
conversation and be like that's cool you
know
my thing is is that if i speculated
terribly on a story and that turned out
to be false and that inspired somebody
to kill three cops i would at least
acknowledge it publicly
you know let me let me explain you know
the the the young tricks rage in in in
this way i i signed a deal with uh
univision's you know and disney fusion's
company it was a two-year contract it
was for a lot of money and when they
started doing bad stuff
and i didn't like it and i didn't want
to play that ridiculous game they just
put me in golden handcuffs where they
were basically like sit back and do
nothing because there's nothing you can
do and i tried breaking i i said will
you let me out of the contract they
basically said no they didn't say it
outright but they're like well you know
let's revisit the conversation later and
then i'm just sitting there like i can't
do anything
now for me i didn't lose my mind because
i had no obligations to be on camera
saying these things i literally was just
like i'm not gonna go on camera and say
these things there was an instance where
i was doing a mini dock on
this cop watch group
and when i was talking to some woman
about police brutality and then i uh it
was it was the craziest thing i brought
up we were just talking and then i
mentioned you know when she said you
know growing up and being asian in new
york you deal with a lot of police
brutality and i was like yeah i was like
my family absolutely dealt with a lot of
the stuff too because you know i'm part
korean and then she she immediately
snapped at me and got really mad and
said no you have no idea what you're
talking about take that back and i was
like but my family did go through this
stuff like we we had bricks thrown
through our window and then i was just
like dude
i if you guys want to finish this shoot
i'm not going to be i'm going to sit
here and and take a racist you know
insults or anything like that i don't
have to be here i don't want to be
involved in this and i'm not going to
i'm not going to be the person on camera
who's in there going like oh i'm so
sorry that i i'm so no i'm not doing it
so they put me in golden handcuffs
but i didn't have to be you know on
camera jank has to host his show
and so what if he starts saying things
like the establishment is bad he did say
the democrats lie all the time i can
respect that but if he starts coming out
and saying you know trump's right about
the the manufacturing base leaving
it's going to hurt the investors
they're going to revolt and they could
come after him for breach of contract
you're hurting the company you are
hurting the investment you owe us so he
has no choice but to sit on this boat
forever for however long it could be
forever it's an investment it could be
forever
he's trapped and he's watching jimmy
dore and glenn greenwald and they're on
the shore waving goodbye as he drifts
further and further out to oblivion and
the reason jimmy has the overwhelming
advantage in their dispute is because
based on the ideological parameters that
jank has set out jimmy's right like
force the vote for medicare for all
basically that's right i've disputed the
polling around medicare for all multiple
times but that doesn't matter they all
theoretically believe that everybody's
in support of medicare for all and now
is the time to do it jimmy dore was 100
right in that progressive sphere which
is why jank lost
publicly in the pr battle for that i
mean i think the young turks are not
long for this political landscape to be
equally honest
and anna did black like that was an
attempted black yeah well explain that
what was that so she so what what ended
up happening is they were going jimmy
was hitting the young turks for a long
time and i've over forced the vote by
name since like november december
whenever he started let's let's start
from that part basically there were
progressives who said
the the squad and progressive members of
congress should withhold their support
for nancy pelosi unless pelosi agrees to
have a floor vote on medicare for all
yeah the young turks were like no
don't do it don't help republicans and
they would make up that there was a
scenario where they could make a
republican speaker which by the way
being a speaker without a majority is
meaningless anyway so even if that
wasn't a lie which it was jank was lying
about that it wouldn't mean anything so
jimmy was calling that out because he
was a big advocate of it and it seemed
like jank was jealous that like jimmy
thought of it or maybe he was trying to
win or trying to preserve relationships
with the squad or something like that
um over time that led into
jimmy attacking jank as a televangelist
because you get 20 million dollars from
katzenberg but you're out there every
day like i need money the funniest email
by far and i'm on the young turks email
list so i saw it is where they said
we'll get you two thousand dollar
stimulus checks if you give us money the
young turks
will pressure people in the democratic
party to get you stimulus checks wow
yeah it's
jenk's fundraising is really greasy and
televangelisty so jimmy's been slamming
him over and over again and again the
rhetorical advantage because the money
and politics argument according to
jank's own logic jimmy's right
so anna kasparian pops into jimmy dore's
dms
and she
runs down this thing she's like i've
been letting you talk like non-stop
about me and tyt and that's gonna end
i'm gonna bring up this time that you uh
like harass me or apologize and she
names like one instance where he
apologized in there not like alludes to
it and then she says one time you um
said that you like my jeans and you
wanted to buy a pair for my wife right
which is for his wife yeah for jimmy's
wife so jimmy like if you get that
message
you have to come out publicly because if
jimmy stopped talking about the young
turks even if it was for a week anna
could have said look i messaged him this
he hasn't talked about us for a week
therefore he knows it's true therefore
he's a scumbag so it's a total setup so
jimmy comes out and tells the story
turns out jimmy dore actually told the
story months earlier oh bump the mic
jimmy told the story months earlier the
same exact story that he told now
without naming anna so like
anna tried to blackmail him in order to
get him to stop and jimmy was
criticizing her on policy her and jank
on policy and she tried to dig up this
thing that he apologized for it was not
that big of a deal i don't know you know
you could listen to the videos jimmy has
it just that whole stuff gets a little
bit too in the weeds of like drama
between personalities it shows how nasty
the young turks are that something that
she jimmy apologized for anna accepted
the apology seven years passed by jimmy
has criticisms of the young turks as a
network and their policy positions and
then they're like oh yeah
shut up or we're going to me to you so
that right so this is where i think it's
in the in the greater context for those
that probably if you don't care about
the young turks and i mentioned a lot of
people now i'm not saying no one cares
about the entrance i'm saying probably
people watch us or like i don't watch
them i do it's indicative of
what's happening to the mainstream left
messaging
the young turks big
powerful prominent they were like one of
the fir they're on youtube tv they have
their own channel and i don't think
they'll last long because
you can't look you know he got booted
from the justice democrats
you can't please this crowd i mean we
just did a was a segment about how the
the black lives matter activists got
boston pride shut down
you cannot have allegiance to group of
people who will just gut you and and
eviscerate you at a moment's notice or
without even a moment's notice so the
young turks are continually embracing
nonsensical policy positions notably
like don't push a vote for medicare for
all i was 100 in favor of the force the
vote not that i thought it could pass
but jimmy said i want to know who
opposes it let the democrats say to
their constituents what they really
believe and i'm like yes
i thought it was hilarious how many
democrats come out and they're like we
absolutely support bernie and they know
their actual core constituency are
moderate and don't want it so when it
comes to the vote they're going to be
like no
so this is where i had the
in in jimmy logic it works this is where
i had the flaw is because it's really
easy to vote yes on a bill that you know
for a fact it's not going to pass anyway
so you wouldn't have really gotten a
good assessment of who's in favor who is
opposed of it perfect example of this
barack obama votes against raising the
debt ceiling as a senator now when he's
president and the republicans are
threatening to actually do that
he had to come out and say look i was
grandstanding like that's what you do
when you know a bill is going to pass
for sure and you think you can
grandstand in voting the opposite way
that's what you do for political points
but
think about
the midterms
when primaries happen and they could say
here's them saying yes or no
make them put their money where their
mouth is i want honesty in politics so
if these people are like
i'm gonna lie for votes
and then when it comes to actually
voting they have to make a choice a hard
choice none of this wish you wash ebs
then when the primary and the midterms
come up they're going to be a video over
and over again of that them saying yay
or nay
or so i i i agree force the vote no i i
i think it fits perfectly if you're in
that camp um but you could also vote
present remember that's right and then
what happens is as jimmy was stating you
get to uh in the primary say they
refused to support medicare for all they
are not progressive
let that be known the p look i don't
agree with with most of what these
democrats want but i i do agree the
constituents have a right to know what
they actually will do i don't want under
this i'll just do whatever the whims and
tides of the day are going to be
this came up before man it shouldn't be
like i'm going to trust this person to
do what they said they're going to do it
should be a smart contract built into
their job they say they're going to do
it when they're running and then they're
bound and it happens automatically
whether they they don't even get to
choose there are issues with that though
like what if they get in and then get
handed a classified document they go oh
wow too bad i i would be i would be fast
tell the people tell the american people
they got a document tell
expose it yup that's true i would be
fascinated if you had them all on record
to see what would actually happen in the
primaries because jimmy's theory of
politics is that if you vote no on
medicare for all
you're losing in the primary i don't
think that's gonna actually
pull out in the like in the correct way
like joe manchin if he voted i know he's
in the senate but if he voted yes on
medicare for all like he'll probably win
his primary but he's losing to the
republican like he has triangulated his
way into that senate seat that should be
a republican senate seat and he's the
most popular politician in west virginia
history by the way as a democrat who is
joe manchin oh geez everybody people
don't like him but the democrats would
not have that their place in the senate
right now if not for him yup a lot of
people pointing out that jimmy spent on
alex jones oh yeah he's spinning out
jones's face that's so nice
yeah i'm not i'm not a fan but you know
alex got up in their space there's a
whole fight
i was there actually at the uh
awards.com yeah that was i think that
was the d was it the dnc was it the rnc
it was the rnc it's the rnc yeah yeah
how's that both i have so much love for
alex jones because i was watching
politics on youtube when there are five
political channels alex jones the young
turks which is why i know so much about
them
uh
uh lee doran if you remember him
and a couple others that i don't want to
name we are change we are changed luke
or dowsie yeah luke where you at
he pops in from time to time yeah one of
the original i think luke might be like
the original political channel no joke
because he's got videos going way back
and he was his first videos where he was
yelling at ziggy berzinski i think it
was
you're a globalist
he's yelling at him whatever
he's come a long way
still yelling about globalism warren 25
was pretty hard cory is that canadian
dude that just screamed at george bush
he was a good friend of mine there's
an issue i know luke moore for but i
can't say it on because i'm pretty sure
it's a youtube thing probably so so
we'll we'll save all that super spicy
stuff for the members only bonus segment
and all the election stuff which is like
some some really big news but you know i
don't look i don't care for most of the
drama
i want to say i think a lot of the young
turk stuff comes up simply because
you know jenk puts out a lot of these
half-baked statements
and i i don't much care for the young
turks i don't care to talk about them
all that often but they are a big and
powerful player in politics it's a
they're a litmus test if anything of
what's happening socially to news media
because they were 2008 2007 is that when
they started i mean they were no no no
way
youtube for that they were making killer
youtube videos or something right they
were on youtube before youtube had
monetization oh yeah yeah so they had
none of that didn't they have their own
website before even youtube existed well
so jank bought the domain
i know too much about the turks chang
bought the domain the young turk in 1996
and the young turks in 1997. okay so old
school and i mean he was very anti-war
in iraq extremely outspoken about the
corruption in the bush administration
and i learned a lot and i think a lot of
people did because of his work but then
you see over the decades it's kind of
like he's transitioning as society is
transitioning and he's like he's just
let me let me explain some of you guys i
i was talking to some guys from vice
and there was uh i don't know if i told
this story on air before because it's
like a you know youtube probably made me
but whatever there was an article from
vice that said this disgusting app shows
you what women look like topless
and it's an app where if you take a
picture of a woman it uses like you know
an algorithm or whatever to generate a
topless image simulates it
and so i was talking these guys from
vice a couple years ago
and they were talking about how so many
people changed they were like man so
many people we knew from advice have
just changed become far right blah blah
and so i was like guys you changed
we didn't i was like i showed him the
article it was a reason at the time or
something like that
i was like you see this article
like this disgusting app can show you
women look like topless and they're like
yeah and i'm like do you know what the
title of that article would have been in
2011 and they were like
oh yeah it would have been this amazing
app can show you because vice was left
sort of but they were edgy oh yeah they
were they they were uh punk rock sex
drugs and rock and roll man not these
stodgy suit wearing conservatives what
we're not gonna wear those suits at cpac
and now vice is moral authoritarian
stodgy
you know do as you're told or else it's
called vice like they changed
they changed so so i bring that up
because there's that video um there's a
a composite video from the young turks
and you can see the things that jenkins
used to talk about like talking directly
about women's bodies yeah mocking no
censorship they were free and
actually it was funny edgy it was free
speech and now they're locked down more
authoritarian
that's the left that's that's the
evolution of the left i should have
watermarked those clips because when
jank announced he was running for
congress i went and i knew all the dirt
downloaded it started uploading it to
twitter and everybody stole it from me
but shout out to stephen michael davis
for starting this whole fight between
jank and jim and jimmy door he's the one
who clipped that whole aaron mate thing
that started this whole thing check him
out on twitter and on youtube great man
i've been entertained for months based
on that one minute long clip
you know i'll say i'll say this right
now and then we'll read super chats the
democratic party is trash i detest them
the neocons all trash they went and
joined the democratic party back in 2016
because of hillary the republican party
the remnants of the establishment
republicans mostly trash but there's a
decent handful of republicans that i can
respect i can respect the populist right
for wanting to fight back the
libertarian party
mostly trash as well party politics but
yeah mises caucus dave smith
now i'm starting to actually dig what's
happening with the libertarian party how
could we do this without parties
i i think i i don't mind party politics
why
it's it's it's sort of like
the problem with certain areas is how it
it breaks down into um
a single party rule that's a problem
but when you look at like how the
primary process works it it serves
similarly a kind of rank choice system
you know so you have a bunch of
different parties
the the people vote for who in the like
so you've got progressive conservative
libertarian and of the progressives
which one should win and then they
choose boop then other libertarians
which one should win and other
republicans the problem is it's devolved
into two-party tribalism right it's not
necessarily the party issue it's the
first pass to the post voting system
where it's one person one vote that
actually doesn't make a whole lot of
sense if you actually go through the
math of the system
because then people end up voting
against instead of four because a vote
for a vote against is typically more
powerful than a vote for
so you think with ranked choice voting
party politics would be less uh incisive
yes
absolutely but ranked choice isn't even
that perfect there's still issues with
it but i certainly like ranked choice
better than
you know i think if we had ranked choice
voting ron paul would have won
i don't know
the problem is everybody says man i'd
love to vote for ron paul but
he's probably not gonna win so you gotta
vote for mccain well how come george
washington when he was leaving office
was like party politics is terrible do
not do it it will be the downfall of our
assistant
he's right about ranked choice cause
right now if like a better candidate if
like biden versus uh trump right and
then there was a third party candidate
that you thought was better but you
didn't believe they could win
voting for them like assuming you wanted
trump to win like you're taking away
votes for trump would cause your worst
choice to win hillary uh biden whatever
um the point of ranked choice is that if
your candidate doesn't get above a
certain threshold or is not going to win
then they default all the voters default
to their second choice i like that a lot
so look dave smith becomes the
libertarian presidential candidate and
then it's biden trump dave smith i go
number one dave smith number two trump
then what happens is if it turns out
dave actually can't win and he only gets
10 percent my vote goes to trump instead
yeah so it stops me from voting in the
lesser of two evils it gives me the
actual ability to choose
and then
what ends up happening is it gives
people the confidence to vote for who
they actually want it's not perfect
there's still still are circumstances
where people end up panicking and voting
because of the way some of these systems
are designed
voting against somebody for sure the
idea is you're more voting for who you
want to win instead of voting against
who you want to leave that's very
important i think if we had ranked
choice voting we'd get a libertarian
president i do um not that i i
completely agree with the libertarian
like i i want to stress i'm not saying i
think ron paul has the best ideas in the
world he's just a million times better
than the establishment because he was
like i'm not going to go to war and i'm
like
sign me up leave me alone hey he's the
candidate for you right oh let's go to
super chats and see what the audience
has to say if you haven't already give
that like button a good smash is greatly
appreciated and subscribe to the channel
go to timcast.com become a member
because you're not going to want to miss
tonight's bonus members only segment
where we talk about the things youtube
would ban us for which is unfortunate
now i know a lot of people have said
some of these segments are too important
to be behind a paywall you are
completely right i 100 agree the issue
right now is that the current version of
the website doesn't actually have a
function by which we can
properly upload
we have new infrastructure coming
hopefully by monday so we should be able
to actually make free like you know
in the proper
s
seo sorted uploaded framed all that
stuff and then make it free if it's
really really important which i think
this one's going to be so anyway
all right let's see we got here cnns he
says tim been a fan since vice found you
again months ago but recently i've been
getting recommended videos that are
definitely hit pieces on some drama from
past colleagues maybe that's how youtube
attacks now i have past colleagues
making drama
i have no idea you know i'll be honest i
completely ignore it all like there's
been there's apparently um i guess ethan
kline was talking about me of course i
think it's hilarious because i i
literally don't care
you know so we we talk about the young
turks right now and i'm always like oh
they might respond and say something to
me i'm not going to engage i'm not
saying this because i want any drama to
exist i have my opinions they can have
theirs about me i'm not going to argue
with them i have no problem if if i ever
saw jankyuger be like hey how's it going
man how's it been it's the business but
he's the one who yelled at me so you
know whatever i'm not i'm not here for
that i just ignore it all you ignored
all uh i will say though um something we
tweeted out
we have a soft lock on a charlie charlie
kirk vosh discussion debate yeah august
3rd so if you haven't um i want i say
soft we we've they've both agreed to it
they both agreed to the date they're
both cool and excited for it and i think
it'll actually be a lot of fun
people like it's going to be a shouting
match maybe a little bit because people
get heated but i don't think it's going
to be as bad i don't think it's going to
be crazy i think it's going to be really
really interesting actually are you are
you moderating it like you're going to
actively moderate probably but there's
another there's another guy i know who's
a lefty that i might have as well
because i don't want to put vos in a
situation where he's got someone who's
kind of libertarian and someone who's
conservative
just
arguing like two you know
yeah i disagree with charlie on a bit
he's conservative we had a fun
conversation with him in will
chamberlain where i'm like here's my
position they're like that's libertarian
we're conservatives but charlie and i
will probably agree on more than we
would with wash so i got another guy who
is a lefty who agrees more with vosh
than he would with either of us so i'm
hoping it would actually just be a big
discussion i can pull up sources and say
hey that's not true that's not true but
we'll figure it out four people might be
too cluttered and i might just keep
quiet i might just not actually engage
and let them talk and then actually just
google what he says and then google what
you know i would i would get them to
agree to a time because they're both uh
i've debated boss he likes to suck up
all the time and i've met charlie kirk
and i've seen him speak he loves
speaking in those 45 second i'm running
for senate clips so you gotta like at
least establish some kind of like you
have two minutes you have two minutes
that's my advice well mute the mic and
then and then charlie went over excuse
me that's the gorilla if you have the
gorilla
no i don't know we'll just
those guys are chill man i love those
dudes but what i wanted to talk to we
had a four hour conversation with bosh
we had a great two and a half hour
conversation with charlie is awesome
what we got what you got to watch out
for ian
and i will not accept is when people
do four or five points in one go you
make a point you got to stop because we
have to fact check it you can't just
keep saying things and it's really
annoying when someone will start saying
something they'll be like you know that
two plus two equals four and then three
plus three plus six and then four plus
four hold on hold on we gotta go back to
two plus two bro you can't just gloss
over and say all of these things and
bring us to a different point of
conversation but a lot then people go
you're interrupting me you're
interrupting
can one of the debate topics be that
charlie kirk is way taller than you
imagine and it's weird huge [ __ ] way
taller than me he's like eight foot
fifty that's true yeah what was he like
six three or six four yeah when i met
him i shook his hand i didn't know who i
was meaning i looked up i'm like oh my
god you're charlie current you looked up
like i was getting up there i mean i
looked like i looked down because i'm
six foot yeah that's right yeah six
seven huh that's true all right let's
see what we got here
kevin burns says federal government
should back off the states tenth
amendment needs to be respected
absolutely through that
all right dark hood order of grace says
first time super chatting just wanted to
say i'm glad to now be a part of the
team as a tim cast membership thank you
all so much for being members oh yeah we
have i think um around 21 employees or
so yeah the vibe is good yeah it's
getting crazy so all of it you know the
weirdest thing is we're at the point
where stuff is happening i don't know
about right you know so i walked to the
house and i'm like oh i was like oh like
i should introduce myself something
happened i kind of wasn't for days and i
was like i really should be more
personable things are happening that i
didn't know were happening that's like
oh man it's all these people i don't
know yeah there's so many people now
like stuff happens like i see an article
pop up on the website and i'm like hello
you know they're working
so it's going to be fantastic
oh yeah all right
all right let's see we got here
just some minced garlic says three of my
co-workers and i quit when they tried to
force critical race courses as part of
training now work for a suppressor
company best change ever that sounds
pretty awesome that's cool let me just
stress to all of you right now
i went to the diner and they have a sign
on the door
we're struggling to staff i walked
inside a whole section of the building
was was you can't sit here understaffed
so they only had one little dining area
they closed at 5 00 pm
if you work for a company and they're
like we're going to get woke and you
look your manager in the eye and say i
will quit on the spot they'll say please
please please don't we can't hire
anybody nobody wants to work oh
you have all the leverage right now as
an employee these companies are
desperate dude i saw a wendy's and a big
banner said open interviews
any time
like i could walk in right now walk i
like an interview please come here there
there are signs on mcdonald's and other
fast restaurants thousand dollar bonus
now i know a lot of people are saying i
don't work for a fast restaurant dude
nobody like people are struggling to
hire i'll tell you this
why is it that we're hiring it's a
high-profile show with a decent amount
of resumes and people want to work and
and we do passion projects so maybe you
work at a company that's not the same as
you know like a cracker factory or a
paper mill or something
but i genuinely believe right now
you will have a substantial amount of
leverage if they try introducing you
know racist trainings like they're doing
with the the critical race applied
principles and you just say i'll quit
you know and and then what happens when
you file for unemployment it's because
my boss was racist it's the biggest it's
the biggest labor crunch uh in recent
history you gotta you gotta go for it
mcdonald's giving away iphones too i
know i saw that wow it's crazy and some
of those uh high-profile jobs because
people have moved away and they're like
if i don't work from home i'm not coming
back if you're just willing to go into
the office you can get a huge pay
increase yeah yeah wow
all right ocd wolfman says so last week
you had been discussing storage of meat
like chicken you can typically store
chicken vacuum sealed and frozen for up
to two years wow i watched a video where
they were water glassing eggs you know
what that is it's like a mixture of lime
and water and you take the egg right
from the from the coop right from the
chicken's butt and you just you put it
in i'm probably getting this wrong i'm
not but there's something there's
something on the egg called the bloom
which is like it seals the egg so you
can put it right in that lime mixture
and and leave it for like up to two
years or something like that
refrigerate it or no no no just in the
bucket i gotta ask is this how they
treat them in europe because i know that
they do not refrigerate eggs in europe
you don't have to if you don't wash them
yeah so because in the u.s they have to
be washed right they become poor they're
porous and then bags go bad yeah yep all
right track media only says peaceful
divorce requires both sides wanting
peaceful and the left wants your stuff
or do you think china and russia are
peaceful when they want something but
that also implies that there's going to
be easily dividable state factions which
i don't think there will be because blue
cities don't agree with the rest of
their red states so what's more likely
to happen is a fracture of confidence
and a general dissolution
i don't think it's going to be like you
might get the enclave like you played
fallout 3 right
no i don't play game station wow what
i don't know any video games that's what
you play it on right a game station
fallout 3 no i don't play games pc
what
computer xbox playstation you play
oh yeah the last game i played was super
mario rpg legend of the seven stars good
game dude that's fantastic fallout 3
there is this very powerful faction
called the enclave it's remnants of the
government so there might be a very you
you might see like you know capital
police like guarding a building and
you're like oh look those guys still are
still around huh but who knows mit says
by 2040. we'll see how that plays out
thundercat says the tim cass crew with
actual justice warrior awesome guys help
me convince my wife to buy a gorilla
shirt we also have the don't snake me
bro shirt which is
a skateboarding or you know it's a skate
park reference snaking someone is when
you cut in front of them when it's like
when they're when it's their turn to
like hit a ramp or a rail or an obstacle
yeah you're cutting in line so it's the
gadsden snake with a beanie on a
skateboard and says don't snake me bro
tim's beard it's great all the
skateboarders were like yeah they're
super excited to wear the gadsden don't
snake me bro shirt
james alford says i looked at the map i
don't like being with colorado if this
happens we need to separate into two to
north and south or east and west and
give people that want freedom the time
to move to the split they want and the
same with the commies i've been telling
you man you got to go somewhere else
get away from the cities move to the
state you want to be in people don't
realize like oregon for instance these
counties want us to see they voted to
secede if the pacific northwest actually
ever did break out break out you're a
serf and then you're trapped
so go somewhere with like-minded people
they might be the only people and they
still wouldn't be able to do it that
could leave without triggering a war
because if if you think about if like
louisiana were to secede
uh that's the port of new orleans that's
the end of the mississippi river no you
can't give that up to another country no
you're going to end up going into war
over that no coastal territory no bread
basket state
maybe a mountainous no no state like you
can't get i mean you want a war dude
yeah every port the feds are not going
to give up a port i mean the reason
andrew jackson's president is because
new orleans was the strategically most
important city when he won the battle of
new orleans because everything had to go
out through the mississippi river texas
is probably one of the best bets but
yeah
i'm worried a bunch of the california
people are moving there and we'll see
what actually happens in texas but they
have the gulf the california people make
texas more red if the election were held
with just native texans beta or work
would be the senator of
texas yeah but are those people from
from california or is that like the
conservatives from all over the country
who are moving in but largely largely
except for austin which is a lefty like
enclave the people moving from
california are the republicans that are
moving it they're keeping it red good i
hope so alex on earth says secession is
a surefire way to get a job cleaning ccp
toilets
i agree yeah that's why it worries me
all right makeshift electric says hey
tim recently heard you saying passing
you wanted someone to make music for you
on a whim i sent some of my stuff to the
pitch's email didn't know where else to
send you played a big role in waking me
up so thank you all hey you appreciate
it yes we're looking for a composer
quite literally we need to hire someone
who will sit in a room making different
music all day that's it
probably a lot of a lot like i'm talking
like
easily like a lot of electronic
production stuff and then
instrumentation whatever you can do but
if there was somebody who knew how to
just do electronic i'd be like make the
music
because we can use it for everything we
do i would love for that person to also
if you could set up microphones all over
the place you know you understand sound
booms um dampening what equipment we
need what pieces all that stuff like the
total package bring it definitely tyler
richie says hey tim what do you think of
elon shouting out dogecoins is this
market manipulation this week he shouted
out daddy doge to mars after his trial i
do think it is but krypto is not
regulated
what is is in his kid mining doge oh
elon says yeah i don't know i i i think
everybody plays this stupid game and
that's a lot of people will uh will
super chat like this is the crypto dubai
and i'm like i know they're saying that
because they want i mean you know is
word of mouth when you're famous market
manipulation i think you know well yes
when when you have a vegetable interest
in the production of a product and you
own a ton of it and then you start
tweeting out hey hey yeah check it out
okay
it's you're sketchy in the legal
territory whether it's technically
actually market manipulative well it's
not it's literally it's it's legally not
there's no laws it is just saying we
know why he's doing it like it is
manipulating the market but it's not
legally
manipulating the market however that
works brown bear says if we have a
peaceful divorce who gets custody
custody of the nukes the region where
the nukes are
the command stations for where they are
that's it
we need a technological solution here
i'm i'm just i'm falling flat right now
but it's it's not an easy solution or
someone would have figured it out
already
brown bear says rock and stone to the
bone hey
dude are you talking about uh deep rock
galactic
it's a game for the pc blackstone it's a
great game by the way oregon trail good
game morgan trail yeah my daughter died
of cholera i was sad yeah i died of
dysentery swimmy says love your work
guys keep it up
uh s o ian i'm a fairly pessimistic
canadian who's sick of living in liberal
land been considering immigrating to the
states but i i don't know jack about the
process south dakota seems mint any
advice
go where your heart is man i don't have
any advice because i don't know how the
process works either yeah
um well you get a job with an american
corporation i do know that biden
basically just lets everybody through
the southern border yeah
you could definitely come visit i think
apparently that's the word for a while
yeah i don't know do we have do we have
um
policies related to the virus for
incoming travelers still
or i don't know i don't know i think so
yeah i think the borders are still
restricted
staunch unionist says tim do you think
the establishment wants to balkanize the
us or do you think the dems just want a
civil war because they think they can
win and take all the power personally i
can't stand the idea of a peaceful
divorce
that's what jack bosobic was saying that
the democrats have the solution but they
need a problem they need some kind of
catalyst so that they can then crack
down and just become the ccp
he was making it really he made a really
great point that when these when these
politicians went over to china and saw
how they can snap their fingers and
create a financial district and just
create an amusement park and then boom
there's disney world they were like how
do we do that
well you got to be authoritarian
how do you do that you've got to get rid
of the constitution
how do you do that you need a civil war
politicians always have more solutions
than there are problems and those
solutions tend to create more problems
so
i'm
i wouldn't be surprised if they have a
lot of ideas they want to implement that
they're waiting for something smarter
covet as an opportunity to remake the
country yeah splinter191 says you asked
what a ward room is it refers to the
officers of a ship it's also where they
eat their meals on fancy dishes and
silverware navy nuke sub vet right on
very cool
okay tarzan jungle kung fu says that
white stripe is actually for the seven
nation army what i was thinking yeah
yep it's jack black so this is uh
spencer spencer rangel says tim the
white in the flag does not represent
whites the combination of blue pink and
white is representing the trans flag yes
but it's not the trans flag
so there's a white stripe on the lgbt
flag
the pink and the blue i understand but
the black and brown there's no like
black and brown flag you know what i
mean
that's kind of weird though the black
flag is the anarchist flag yeah
they got their fist one right
what is what is what is what is black
and orange is that just like uh what
what what's narco centrist what's black
hammer's flag look like
that organization if you've never have
no idea it's a ghazi kodo's organization
jeez
all right let's see
caliber neutral says i've looked on the
old site but will ian's nude model
calendar where he makes graphene sexy
again be on the new site yeah we
actually shot some footage today andreas
and i oh my gosh yeah wasn't nude
finished up the year wasn't nude oh no
the calendar will be on my website
if i end up going nude i was thinking
about doing nude yoga
maybe we put that on tim castle dude
nude hot yoga teamcast.com this company
is going thank you ian
blackrock beacon says biden is more like
nero trying to cross the rubicon
nero was a kid that was like inbred or
something right emperor and he went
psychotic and like had all this hate and
rage and but he was an emperor so at age
12 he would like
have all these orgies he had these huge
boats built that he would uh
no i'm thinking of i'm thinking of that
what's the sex kid
the roman sex emperor i'm thinking of
colleen
yeah nero was the one who played the
fiddle while rome burned they think that
maybe he actually lit rome on fire
cool
and like false flagged it relentless
hemi says just subscribe to
timcast.com yes you're legit relentless
thank you so much
welcome all right
alex says ps love you guys huge fan you
made me turn democrat to center of right
tim and also i'm the only republican
libertarian in my whole family
oh no is that the radicalization that
biden's been talking about
yeah
i guess so it's funny because like i
could actually you know have a good
conversation about
um left libertarian policies the problem
the reason why i would rather have
ron paul
as like a more right libertarian is
because he under a right libertarian
system you're allowed to have your left
libertarian system and so i'm kind of
like you know leave me alone and let me
do my thing and if me and my you know
homies can have a farm where we like
grow our own food and i'll share it and
everything and do our little left lippy
lip libertarian hippie stuff i'm i'm
right i'm cool so you know that's what
i'm all about
the problem is when they try to
scale it up
the only way to scale up left
libertarianism is to become
authoritarian there's there's literally
no big scale left libertarian
immediately or if you you you become
christian have you ever you've ever seen
the studies of the communes the
christian ones
outlast way more than marxist
they ask for like a collective sacrifice
and there's a religious basis for it
marx's communes are like the one that
bernie sanders was in where they're like
dude you're not working get out i kicked
him out for not working they kicked him
out for being too lazy
that's my favorite story it's amazing
all right travis
kondik says first ever super chat i just
want to invite everyone to come together
and have a good time every saturday for
the million doge disco decentralized
dance party 100 about fun and love
excellent bliss says hey tim two things
one could you point me to where i could
apply for a job on your site
twenty-year-old millworker but i really
don't fear repercussions from the left
two you ever try pop corners what is
what is that
i don't know um jobs at timcast.com
and man i think probably by next year we
might have like 50 to even 100 employees
yeah we already need like more space
yeah but we are growing really really
quickly the new site's going to launch
and then we're going to work it's going
to go real fast and it's going to slow
down a bit
because it's a it's big investment so
that basically means like the people
we're hiring there's no guaranteed
actually become sustainable
but some things are worth doing
regardless of whether or not they have
direct monetary returns like basically
the vlog for instance we do definitely
not profitable right now but it could be
more importantly it's excellent
marketing value for the company and it's
excellent culture building yeah so
there's real value to that i'm sure you
got like a legal team but you need to
look into where that employee cut-off is
in this state
oh yeah i know it's like 51 employees is
usually what it is so
this is the thing people need to realize
about why companies eventually take on
that 20 million dollars because jen
probably hit a point where he he crossed
the threshold and then immediately got
slammed by massive regulation and then
in order to become compliant didn't have
the money to do it because you cross
that threshold and all of a sudden your
business is now in a different you know
territory it's going from 51 to 52
employees is like going from 25 to 51
like that's how much more expensive when
all those regulations kick in
yeah there's a whole bunch of really
crazy regulations that happen once you
cross in most places i think it's 50
employees once you get to 50 all of a
sudden everything lights up and then
man
that's the biggest bummer so i'm
wondering if what makes more sense is to
actually um
somewhat compartmentalize and keep
companies focused like if we're going to
do something like we we're we're
developing a video game that should
probably be spun off into its own
company because there's no point in
cluttering up a system with something
that's you know more peripheral to what
everyone else is doing
but you know
yeah
all right good luck on your uh expansion
also i would say we should utilize
contractors i don't know what you feel
ethically about that yeah of course we
we do they're not considered employees
though right right so it's just like
them no no no there's i mean there's
limits but the idea is a contractor
would be someone who submits an article
and then we're like hey it's cool we'll
bite off you
you know
you can't have permalancers where you
contract someone and have them work
every day basically can you not you
cannot no
youtube that's that's what we are on
according to youtube we're freelancers
no they say they're royalty payments oh
yeah yeah
probably that's the reason joshua vote
says hello from nj instead of
balkanization how would you all feel
about a mass cleansing of federal
government by that i mean anyone who has
been in for more than 15 years in
politics are gone also how do you all
feel about term limits for all
politicians
i'm not
i'm i don't know enough about term
limits we've had really good arguments
on the show about why they're good and
why they're bad i think they're great
and people say if somebody wants to vote
for someone let them vote for them and
it doesn't matter if they're accurate
politician or not they're gonna be
supported by the machine all the same so
they'll just find more people
so i i don't know how about this theory
that i heard today actually should we
pay politicians in the house and the
senate 10 million dollars a year
andrew yang was talking about that he
said that if they're paid a ton of money
then they're going to be very loyal to
that system that makes them rich and not
to
but that still makes no sense so the
answer is no well it's it's actually
because they manage trillions of dollars
of money and they're making less money
that they can make on any like
reasonably high wall street job so
should we pay them enough to attract
people who are talented from those
fields to run for office i would create
a bonus structure yeah if they can uh
reduce the deficit they'll get a
percentage as their salary for the year
otherwise they're saying it's one dollar
if the economy improves they get a
percent they get the the raise based on
it i like the idea of politicians
getting paid what the middle class
median is
then their incentive is to make sure the
middle middle class meeting is very high
there you go
it'll work but they don't but we don't
want congress controlling what the
median income is like we don't want them
setting wages ah sean b says tim it's
not lime it's a liquid silicate product
literally liquid glass been used for
many years as a concrete sealant oh
interesting
there you go jm says you should try to
get patrick [ __ ] he helped founded
greenpeace and he's pretty cool we have
reached out to him in the past i think
covert really jammed everything up but
we'll definitely reach out to him he is
really awesome i'm a fan he's very pro
nuclear energy and has been and he i
looked into him after i worked at
greenpeace and i was wondering why they
weren't looking into nuclear and why
they opposed it so much and then i read
about the history and i was like oh look
at that
[Music]
all right let's see we had a youtube did
the the famous super chat jump
super damp
so uh all right frankie sharat says tim
how can our company sponsor you there
should be an email listed in the about
section of this youtube channel i guess
because we have we have a manager who
does the ads for us um
should be there i guess
all right let's see where we're at
john hemelman says i'm from i'm from a
small town in minnesota the people here
are mostly to minnesota nice to express
or even hold strong political opinions
not watching the news is considered a
virtue it's very frustrating also
reagan's 1984 opponent was from
minnesota ah so that's why mondale won
minnesota and i believe it was one point
reagan one uh lost by wow wow
crazy and then what was the other 49
state landslide that was um
nixon two maybe was it nixon two yeah
which is weird because that's the one
where he broke into the thing oh wow
nothing
all right let's see we'll just uh we'll
get a couple more super chats here i
love you guys by the way super chats
mayor mercury says i just sent you an
email to info timecast.com about the
musical composer audio engineer job let
me know if you would like samples of my
work please send samples to jobs at
timcast.com and absolutely so we would
really just i knew one guy who would
literally sit around all day and just
make
electronic music of like different kind
of genres but just on his computer and
he had like thousands of them i'm like
that's what we need because we need to
be able to be like hey can you make a
song like this like we need it for the
show we need for this show we need it
for that show uh or we want to actually
make the music and make release it as a
song or something like that
make some music plus i got a million one
songs that need to be recorded and
produced and released as well so we want
an in-house music producer we also have
a pretty sweet drum kit but what we
don't have is a drummer so
i hope you play the drums
bring the nice yeah you know i think
people can play well let's get actually
tim's a drummer
yeah i played i've been playing drums
since i was i was like seven yeah i want
a medal
yeah i want to i want a gold medal
drum off did jk simmons like yell at you
while you're learning to play
no
no
but the best part was i got to leave
class to go to drumming practice that's
beautiful so i'd be sitting to look at
the clock when i was in like fourth
grade
and then it would like hit it was like
some obscure number like 10 10 a.m so
like everyone's in class and also and
i'm just like i get up and i walk over
and i grab my snare drum and i just
leave
all right what is this
bell's nickel says you guys need to
canoe the shenandoah steps at harper's
ferry and go tubing on the shenandoah
some weekend
andreas bought a bunch of these giant
rubber duckies yeah
to go
rubber ducky too still hot yeah yeah it
could be good vlog content uh i will say
though as an aside man you mentioned the
heat ian yeah
so uh this morning when i was going to
get eggs for my breakfast i noticed
something do tell one of the eggs was
fertilized
oh that chicken the rooster been busy
robbie bobby and now it's it's at 90
degrees it's 94 degrees outside for the
next like a couple weeks
i'm just gonna let him have some babies
he's getting busy he is so what'd you do
you crack it open and there was like a
there's something called like a german
nation disc or something you can see
it's they're getting it all so i'm just
going to leave i'm going to leave those
eggs
because i we have two chickens that are
laying and i cracked them both open and
i saw the one that was fertilized
so we'll just let the babies happen does
that make you an uncle or a grandfather
like how does how does that work
godfather when you when you own a
creature and it has kids what do you
call it just you know i don't know jesus
i have dominion over them yeah you do
pick your title go with god king of
north
it's korea so uh it's uh one's what's
what's what's the black and white one
the bard rock rock yeah plymouth hard
rock plymouth bard rock and uh rhode
island red are gonna have babies and
they're gonna look funky so they're
happy for him
[Laughter]
living in living the
living the dream and we're going to give
them a big chicken city where that's
being built out in the next couple of
weeks and then we're going to so a lot
of people are like where's chicken city
we're trying to do the website we are
like focusing everything on this website
done as fast as possible and then we're
going to have the chicken city channel i
spent some time with chickens today got
a little vlog content i don't know if
it'll be on the vlog but check it out if
it'll work out all right everybody if
you have not done so smash that like
button subscribe to the channel go to
timcast.com become a member
the very important election bonus
segment will be coming up
make sure to follow us on facebook and
instagram at tim cast irl run tick tock
at tim cast underscore irl because we do
not want to seed territory in the
culture where we want to be active on
every platform where we can be post
clips share them and hopefully we can
get people to come to our site and learn
and pay attention to news you can follow
me personally at tim cast and uh is
there anything you wanted to shout out
sean oh you know follow me on youtube
actual justice warrior on twitter at i
am sean 90. spelled the traditional
irish way and that's about it don't
follow me anywhere else there you go you
can also hit me up at ian ian crossland
uh dot net and at ian crossland on
social media i want to shout out eric
finnman's uh
freedom phone you guys see this new
phone he was he was here he was here we
met him yeah he came with alan bakari
one night and showed us this new phone
he's been working on i mean he was the
youngest bitcoin millionaire that's
right and now he's he's paying it
forward and he's built this awesome new
phone i'm really excited to uh yeah so
to find out more about that i tweeted it
out a little while ago awesome i'm glad
ian brought that up because i had a
conversation with eric the other day i'm
very excited for where he's going with
that little freedom phone thing uh
facing all this censorship seems like a
great time to get into some freedom
stuff you guys are more than welcome to
follow me on twitter at sarah patch lids
as i attempt to gain more followers and
sour patch kids very important to me
please do so we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you